Here we go. Three, two,
one. My phone's off.
Oh, we're live. Ladies and gentlemen.
This is a fight companion podcast.
If you've ever listened
to one of these before,
oftentimes we don't even watch the fights,
but we're talking some more things.
Yes, but we're watching the fights.
Certainly at least some of the time.
There's more to life than fight.
Did you guys decide to go?
Did you call each other and say, let's,
let's double blast with the Lilac,
or is that just quizzes? Just luck to
happy coincidence. Geniuses were purple.
I just decided to wear a purple.
I got here,
he's wearing purple and he's got a
fucking purple car, so he doubled purple.
Oh yeah. Well, that car,
if you're against me now,
I've read that Lilac,
and I'm going to call that Lilac is
actually a head Turner with the ladies.
They're drawn to the color. Really? Yes.
So they say if you're going to go out on
a date or you're going to go out on the
town, you might want to throw some
lilac on your body, or maybe ladies,
we'll see the lilac and think
you're trying too hard. Maybe,
but it suits my eye and I can't
take my eyes off your torso,
but yet you don't like
his car, his car. Well,
you told Joe that allows, let's get rid
of that. Yeah. Well that he doesn't know.
He looks,
he goes,
what do you have a wing on the back and
I finished her decubitus ask down. Fuck.
Well we don't need that fan. I do. They
actually make your touring package. Hey,
the gt three. You just attacked
my personage of the windbreaker.
I mean he's like one of them.
Jogging Dad. No, I'm not. I'm John.
I'm an athlete and athletes keep their
muscles but educate them on the wing. No,
the wing keeps the acid down. That's
what it does. It's dying for us.
But here's my card.
How come you bought a car in La
traffic where you got to keep the acid?
Wilson traffic, but no, I
have one of those two. Right.
You know I have one with a wing gt three
Rs tale. Isn't that what they're called?
No, that's different. The whale tail
is like a, it's like, it's different.
It's like the turbos.
They had a whale tail.
It's like a flat looking kind of
thing that is a part of the rear deck.
This is lifted above the
rear deck and actual tail.
It's more, it is more effective than
they have whale tails anymore. No,
the whale tails went out with the
1993 turbo. Expensive to buy now.
I guess he could look in a whale, tail,
cars, cars, cars like that. Our instinct,
because it's like the psychologic
thing for all guys. It's like,
at least I know I have the power under
my hood. I'm never going to use it,
but I know I still have a Tesla.
We all want to know we have it.
Listen to what you're just doing. What
that text data mail bro. No, not know.
Just cause I'm in a windbreaker.
Right? Is there a Beta common? No.
Uh, drive the totality, Bro.
If you drive fast,
it's literally results in hundreds of
pounds of downforce fast and you don't
have to drive that fast
to feel the difference.
Have you ever been out of second
gear in that car? Of course.
Who'd have to go very fast
policing? Listening. I really do.
You Beta irresponsible,
but you have to that fucking Tesla that
thinks fast as shit. I, well my buddy,
you know France cap that Frank Grillo
has the hatch to put the headphones talk
over other,
he's got that dodge.
Um, here's a challenge or horsepower.
He has like a Hellcat that souped up.
Oh yeah, I beat him. What you
saying? I beat him off the line.
Posts of your racing irresponsibly
on the streets. Children,
my traffic fast and furious
started revving his engine.
Don't rev your engine at me. I'm
good. But if you rev your engine,
I mean I'll meet you halfway and
carry your engine. Doesn't even,
rev was actually just just be cool
about it. I let him make his noise.
We're going to get from it.
You're going to get that new roadster,
the one that they launched
into space soap as fuck.
You're going to get out of it.
He's got a 600 mile range.
It's lighter and they have more room
for batteries and they're more efficient
with the battery software and everything
is a problem with the test of the
roses. It looks cool. The
roads still looks dope.
It looks like a combination of a
Ferrari and Lotus. You never seen it?
No. Pull up that uh, that,
my problem with the Tesla right now is
that the battery doesn't last long enough.
It just doesn't have anywhere
to charge it. Get better though.
Like the newer ones that every year to
get better, better, better. There it is.
It can handle it. It's pretty
dope. Handle space that roof up.
Put the roof down. Shame. You draw a
picture of the roof down. Kids call it,
get the titties out. They
get that Sun. 1.9 seconds,
1.9 seconds. 60 that's a demon.
That car will make your fucking rs.
Porsche.
Watch your slow like mine.
We'll get one nine seconds. Zero to 60.
That is a dope call. Can I, you know what?
250 miles an hour to 21 mile range.
It just doesn't do it for me to
do it for you. Hope that car,
I need a v 10 I need a Fucking v
eight you have an inline say line six.
I need something pretty gnarly though.
Look at that.
I'm getting that is just so I can be fast
on Brendan, just so I can laugh at you.
You'll be a lot faster. You could
drive that car to Vegas, dude,
off in that car. I wouldn't, I
wouldn't do that unless he was wearing
less. He was, I don't know
man. I just can't get behind
the electric car. You will.
Well, you've seen the Porsche. You've
seen the Porsche Electric car coming out.
If it's going to do it, it
can be Porsche, Porsche.
It looks like dog shit compared to
that dude, I don't test anymore.
How much does that tie can tilt the no
worse than tiny all electric one that
looks like shit, but Jamie
bring that shit up. Porsche,
I think it's called a tie can or
something like that. Take hat. It looks.
It looks very similar to that, but
way cooler. How much is that tissue?
How much of that roadster?
Tesla,
they don't know yet because it hasn't
been released, but 200 200 yeah,
look at that. What? That
does not look nearly.
That's a nice give us.
The test kept pretty similar
but it's a beautiful car.
Looks way better and I'm
not saying because my good
friend Ilan Musk makes it by
the way, we're good friends. Oh my God, I
liked it. That's not doe text each other.
Do you on Musk? I'm his friend is your
best friend. It's got bottom o'clock.
See that clock over there? I got him one
of those. Oh Shit. Tgt Studios clogging.
No big deal.
I think I've nothing weird about that.
Don't be scared of that wheat does.
He still trying to build that subway
underneath that mother fucker is trying to
sell everything. He if you, if
you like talk to him in private.
I wish I could try his brain out for a
day and find out what's going on in there
but it's just rattling around
information constantly.
Things are flying around and grabbing it
and stuffing it into boxes and digging
holes under the ground and shooting
things to the moon. He's just, he just,
his brain just doesn't stop.
He's single. He is now hollow.
When you talked to guys like
that who are lateral thinkers,
like you realize like the guy who made
me feel really dumb and almost like a
fraud was Brendan shop, not
breading shop. Peter Teal.
I tell I was listening to him
talk and I went, yeah, I met him,
I had dinner with at his house and I,
and I was like,
he was talking and I realized
that everything I say is
basically an amalgam of
the things I've read or heard.
And these guys are the ones
who write those things.
He just thinks up things on his own.
He started paypal with you on God. Damn.
That's all those boys got rich. Yeah.
Paypal. It's one of the ways, well,
whenever you think you're a black belt,
you realize you're a white belt. There
you go. By Pat, I shit. To me he's pushed.
Ilan. Ilan went on the podcast.
When you ask them a question though,
he really downloaded that data before you
gave it. Oh boy. He's long pauses. He's,
he's, I would say he's
very, uh, he's enthusiastic.
Almost like a child was certain
things that with his blow torch, guns,
stuff like that.
But when it comes to thinking about
things like he'll just sit down and pause
before he gives you an answer.
He wants to like really consider smart
cause I just go and then fucking Tesla.
He's thoughtless.
But that's also one of the charms of
you is that you say stupid shit that you
wish you didn't say right after you said
it. Right? Right after he said, I know.
He's like, God damn. I
probably should have said that.
Yeah, my tie crusher. Yeah,
but look how well it's going.
Yeah.
I mean you do a showtime special fucking
two and a half years into comedy.
Not even right.
How many years in the comedy,
but I just want to film it to and
change to and change at south sac.
That's outstanding. I say stick
with what got you to the dance.
That's exactly right. Verbal diarrhea
just keeps going until I get assassinated.
Fascinating. Things will get sick. Yeah,
it's going to be fixed on the wall.
You're saying funny shit.
Why do you think you'd get assassinated?
Mad Shit. Which guy? I say crazy shit.
What's the referee wearing? The referees?
Like wearing something around his
waist punch? No, no, no. It's like a,
it's an electronics are
sleazebags a fanny pack. Is it?
And maybe she has a fat Dick Cause he
know. See what I'm saying? Both sides.
He's carrying something. It looks like in
the front. Maybe it is a fanny pack. Um,
Tim, we don't know who's fighting
Jane Lane. Jinguang is a bean.
The Chinese a water.
Yes he is.
Is he in UFC folks watching at home?
Four minutes and 37363530430 three
seconds into the first round.
Dude. Fuck this card. If it
ain't chuck Tito. Oh Shit.
Well they find it today,
right? Guess? Yeah,
that's fine.
They're fighting tonight.
Is there an undercard for that or are
they just in a car with great shape,
right? Yes. They both look in
great shape. Chuck has a gigantic,
a vein across his bicep. They've been
tested to consign pretty straight.
Always had that like kind of his belly
always sticks out. We call it the power.
God's power gut.
He's always had that even when he was
at the top of the food chain yet when he
was the best light heavyweight. Oh
Shit. So water clipped him. Damn.
Jim Lang. Even when chuck was at the top
of the food chain, he always had that. Oh,
it's just, that's just how he's
built. He's just built odd.
Tito was pointing at it. It was really
funny. He was like making fun of him.
But he was wearing a shirt.
Yeah, he didn't have, it
didn't make any sense. Strange.
You were in a shirt.
The whole thing's been a little strange.
I think they should have done like a,
cause those guys should go out on their
shields as hall of famers. I think.
I wish you know trucks had, when they
wanted to do the fight he called Dana.
Dane was like, get the fuck out. It
ain't happening. Good luck though.
And so I wish they were done like a tough
finale or like a big card and they're
just like a feature of
shit. Aye. Aye. Aye Support.
Everyone's right to do whatever they
want to do whenever they want to do it.
As long as they're not hurting anybody.
And this goes into that, right.
I support your right to bull ride.
I support your right to sky dive
and do whatever you want to do, man.
And if these guys like what is,
what are, what is our thought?
And if they don't do this, they're going
to live forever. No, I mean they, they,
they know the risks. They're big boys.
Yep. You know the real question is like
should they be doing it and went through
all the testing because I said I truck
into both on my show.
I asked Chuck,
I'm like you've gone through all the
testing with commission California.
Cause when I was fighting going
through California commissions,
they are by far the strictest.
You do not want to fight here if you're
taking protein powder, they're the worst.
Chuck's like I went through all
the California commission shit.
I'm like damn well I'm everything.
I'm a big fan of this guy who runs it
in California. Andy Foster, he's obese.
He's really on top of the ball. He's
super proactive. He's really smart.
He used to fight himself lifelong martial
artists for respect for the sport up,
super progressive about
people's weight cuts.
It doesn't want people cutting a
shitload of weight in his state.
He tries to monitor their hydration,
wants to get your weight out in advance.
He's ahead of it with everything.
He's not a dinosaur. He said no,
he's ahead of it.
Also with weight classes,
they instituted more weight
classes in California for early on.
So you guys aware of
how one FC does there?
When I talked about how did they do that
and ask how do they do it? They don't.
There's no weight cutting man. There's
no way cutting. They do hydration tests.
They do hydration tests. You fight
whatever is closest to your natural way,
which I think makes a move there.
The one fc 100% is doing it
better than anybody else.
Hundred percent you know the problem with
that is though something, well Connie,
yes, they stopped the weight cutting.
It's not necessarily, it's the division.
So the division is what you weigh what's,
so Ben her and went up to one 85 he was
one 70 and they jumped him up to one 85
which is like his real walk around
weight, you know, and he's still,
and they determine what that weight is.
There's this,
there's gotta be an official
land has got to be, look,
you could always manipulate your weight
and stay healthy within a certain range
of your discipline. They say can you
would still be hydrated. So if you like,
say if you said your best weight is one
65 you just decided that all you would
have to do is make sure you got your
body weight down and do it over a long
period of time so that you're, you know,
you're doing cardio, you're eating right,
you're making sure and then
keep your weight in that range.
Like you could decide to fluctuate 10
pounds one way or the other and still be
fairly healthy.
It's just a matter of how much certain
kinds of exercise you do and how much
time. But the thing about
the certain kinds exercises,
once people got some power,
they don't want to give that power up.
Right.
And if you're like one 75 but jacked and
you really would be better off one 65
but a little thinner,
you know like cardio wise,
a lot of guys don't want to give
up that path. But also, you know,
some guys are huge for their weight
class and for whatever reason like there
until, and who's the guy in
Baltimore who, who lost Rory,
mark them in the first title fight,
Rory Macdonald, Lima, Lima, he,
those guys are giant for their way.
Class East.
And I think sometimes some
people have the kind of body,
like some people have
a body like they have,
they have their two 30 but their weight
on their ass and legs and they have
small upper bodies. And maybe
that's not as good as someone like,
I don't know who has like
there until [inaudible] until
that's all well and good.
But the real thing should
be what do you really weigh?
All the other stuff is bullshit.
All the other stuff is just,
we've just agreed upon this cause we've
been doing it this way for so long.
It should be get to a healthy weight.
What do you way,
and there's gotta be more weight class
from a wrestling background. Right?
We're getting all, there's copy and
roasting the hydration. They, they um,
they make you urinate and they check
your urine and they check the weight of
your urine.
That's one of the ways.
There's a bunch of different sophisticated
ways to do it, but they, yeah,
because the more minerals and the
more stuff is in your, your urine,
it indicates how much water you have
in your body. Like what, you know,
what percentage of of water
you have in your body,
whether or not you're dehydrated.
Just make sure that I'm,
I might be wrong about that.
Double up on the P uh, uh, clear.
That means you're more hydrated.
Yes.
But it doesn't necessarily know if
you've taken a bunch of vitamins,
you can still peek dark yellow.
My Shit will be tucked
to and some of it does
come out in your urine,
but some of it still is
getting absorbed in your body.
It's not all of it that's
going out in your urine.
It's still a good idea to
take multivitamins. One
FC hired a Misha Tate too.
I was like the, she's moving. They're
just going to move to Singapore.
I think it's a smart movement. She's a
smart girl. Sam is a great place to live.
Hey Man. I mean they might, um,
they might seriously be looking at
her as like a big time executive.
Like the female Dana White fur for Asia.
Sounds like that's what they're doing.
Well Rich Franklin is doing it too though,
right?
Isn't he have a big role over there as
well? Huge role does he do over there?
I'm not sure what he does,
but
he did.
He's got,
he's got like some kind of executive job
and does he live in Singapore as well?
Was headed there. They're not going to
commit to you unless you commit to them.
Brandon barrel just one.
Did He, was that in one ft?
Did you see his fight to Brian
and like two years doing it.
Oh monster and have you, it's
amazing dude. He looks so good.
Diabetes either and he wasn't
eating Olympic, a Greco guy.
Brandon Vera. No, he was a
very big, very high level.
Very good wrestler. And you know
what the funny thing is, he's really,
what he's known for is his
kickboxing. Amazing. You know,
he had a hard time in the UFC
dude because there was this,
there was this one period of time where
they were in contract negotiations and I
feel like he lost a lot of momentum there.
Cause remember he uh,
he beat Frank Mir,
frank man and goes and then goes,
I'm going to be the light heavyweight
champion and heavyweight champions. Yeah.
What's up and then their issues.
Yeah, he was like out for a while.
Long time. He got it. He knows
fucking, we came back and the didn't,
he also fight Fabricio for doom
and he got trapped under the mount,
wasn't it for doom? Who? Tk
outcome was it for doom. I re,
I remember feeling like
virgin just handled,
I remember you realize he had really
good Jiu Jitsu because remember he
submitted a us, what's that
dude's name? Brazilian cat.
Fuck,
I forget his name now,
but he's [inaudible] Silva
be like getting dude dude,
dude kills duty training.
I was there with him at 10 plant one
day but he was going to drop the squad.
He dropped in a few times but he
was also trained by a homeboy.
Rob Cayman. No for kickboxing, but
he was in San Diego Alliance.
He's, he doesn't last forever,
but he was a black belt. Who's the
black dude? Uh, Boyd Urban. Yeah,
exactly. He's a little boy. Brandon. Well,
what's crazy is how is his wrestling and
his grappling was like what you would
think if you looked at his skillset,
but it's like he,
he just got so good at striking like
early on he was known more of a striker
than anything by far.
Do you remember when Frank Meir came
back after the motorcycle on the accent?
Like here's Brandon Vera and
Brandon barreling. Cool story.
Nay Nay and just fucked him up to my head.
Kick knock out to
like
in the UFC big time head kicked out,
knocked out Frank Mir with a
head kick who smashed his nose.
His nose got so fucked up in one fire
member knows was literally completely
fantastic. It was great. We
had some tough fights, man.
You see him soccer kid do wrong
when they let him do what.
I've kicked people on the ground if
first of all, he's so much, dude,
he's so jack now or soul he fought
was like other soccer kicks,
not worried June. So you're allowed to
kick that. Guys. Guys are on the ground.
He soccer kick drum calm water.
It's bad.
That's not a good look
on their back fighting.
But that friend,
that soccer head kicked,
I'll make you rethink the side your head
and think there's so much power in that
part of the game is probably the most
powerful kick you could do. Honestly.
It's like it's one of those weird kicks.
It doesn't really show up in martial
arts except if there, you know,
you allow someone to kick someone when
they're down because that's the only time
or ever you can generate that kind of
power because if you really think about it
like everything else, you've got to kind
of teach your foot to do this. Yeah,
you got to teach your body to do this. You
teach yourself. But this kid does that.
Everybody's talking
about the Charlie Brown.
Charlie Brown from like one foot away
and just fucked [inaudible] head.
He really,
everybody can do that.
Jamie brings Brandon verb first
of all we can somebody anyways.
It looks like a video game cause
he used to be flat. It was flat.
No Saginaw Street fighter.
Street fighter.
Definitely eating a lot of
steak. Yes. What do you think?
He's like two two 40 maybe.
Boom and that's just one.
That's just one look at this was a y.
Oh Jesus. But this one is
a bad, that's just one.
There's another one when he's head
kicking the guy while the guys down,
it just sucked.
He was like the first real like a
big time athlete that I remember.
But some people think that
this is a better way to
express fighting because this
is realistic,
like disagree back the head head.
I like Eddie guys are steady,
loves that shit too. Barbaric man.
I would like to see headbutts bring,
oh this fight is over.
That's Cam boot train rounds. We're not
even paying attention. It's fighter. Oh,
we're watching an extraneous fights.
This is when people get mad.
No one called attention to these fights.
The good fight.
This is actually a really good fight.
And you know,
UFC fight pass is working
on getting this league that,
I think it's in Burma where uh,
you just wrap your hands.
It's Muy Thai kickboxing with headbutts.
Yeah. Legal. What is it called?
Leche way. How'd he say it? Yeah,
it's like, it's called let, let, let,
let way that way or something
like that way. I think
that word [inaudible] crazy with them
in front of the ropes on their hands.
They wrap their hands up with something.
I'm not sure what,
I'm barely headbutts or legal holy show.
Frank Grillo in a fight world,
went to Cambodia and lived with
them and study with them and they,
the problem is they don't have
ice in Cambodia. They're so poor.
So when they get hit in the face and
stuff there, they just stay swollen.
So between rounds left way and that's why,
wonder how they search.
I wonder how you pronounce the shots,
elbows nd it against the ropes.
Boom. Just do, just drop.
And Are you
allowed hit to the back of the head? You
can do ever. I'm not sure about that.
You Know Eddie and I've talked about
this a hundred times, but it's,
it's an important fact that
when you watch head kicks,
there's a lot of the time head kicks
are lending to the back of the head.
Like you say, you can't hit someone
in the back of the head, right?
It's not supposed to be legal.
If I go over your shoulder
and I kick you kick in,
the back seats are Nestor who pseudo.
So two punches.
This guy at turn, it hits him, right
my fucking back. Then bring up,
bring up and there's nothing you can do.
Bring up Ernesto host when he hits a
Maurice Greene myth. And Maury Smith.
Yeah Dude.
He wrapped his head around your fucking
head and his neck just goes around your
head. His neck. Just why? Oh,
that was um, that was tough.
I was good friends with Maurice
when that was going on. Maurice was,
was fighting when,
you know,
he probably shouldn't have been done
doing the demos finest Ernesto host is,
you know,
but I mean he was fighting like pro
kickbox and what he's also doing MMA and
like Maurice is a worldclass kickboxer
but I really think for you to fight a guy
like Ernesto hoost,
you kind of have to be kickbox and all
the time and we'll see what he does.
Yeah.
And Maurice like for real was
a super skilled world champion.
Kickboxer but he had been doing,
oh my God.
How do you look at that? He lifts
his watch. This dude, he was so good.
It's perfect. Numbers. Fights
against Bob Sapp. Yeah, Dude.
His fucking leg kicks man. They're the
best at the way he punches though. Yeah,
he bought, he did everything awesome.
The thing about him didn't you know.
Here's another one. Look at him now.
Look it. He looks like a super fight.
A game too,
right?
Doesn't he look like some kind of
video game character in these images?
Well then show to him early in his
career he was a bag of bones man.
Really? Yeah, he was skinny.
What do you think your
diet for real?
He was real thin.
He was very long and almost
like style bender like great.
Then he got Super Jack
later in the cro cop dude,
his leg kicks were sensational. How
about with Bob? Sat beat him twice.
That was a real fight. Fuck
you. That feels real to me.
To add pop SAP is a giant human being.
[inaudible] 75 it's
a lot of fights. He's right. It
bumps up out the fuck up shoulder.
Was it Ernesto?
I don't remember.
They kept hitting it and that's what
stopped the fight. No, no, no, no, no.
That was a different fight. I think you're
thinking of a different phone. I'm not.
One of them had a really fucked up
shoulder and he kept kicking it and he was
like, Nesto kip king.
He was like, no, no, no.
Pretty sure that's Bob had to be one that
he lost because he won the two fights
that he had against her Nesto that
I'm aware of. Box I did, didn't he?
Eddie pops have beat her Nesto yeah.
I told her I don't remember the second
fight or if they even fought twice or
three times. I guess I just
remember Bob up beating him.
Do you know when you
really think about it, man?
You know Maury Smith worked
with Bob Sapp as well,
taught him a lot about kickboxing,
but when
you think about it more,
Reese was like the first real high level
kickboxer to become successful at MMA.
Yup. Right. The first world champion,
when you remember when he fought
Conan Silvera and head kicked him,
everybody was like, you can't beat
a Brazilian jujitsu black belt.
You're definitely not going to beat him.
And by Coleman Coleman Dude,
and he was so as I we were at.
That's why it's against, right.
We were there together. God Damn.
I remember being so 1996 the shit,
right? 96 97 I think it was 97 97 it might
have even been [inaudible] 98 he kept
saying, come on, come on,
come on. Who's come on mark.
How many come granted pounding
and you saw and you saw it.
Mark at one point got
kicked one too many times.
It's just wet stopped and everybody went,
oh, you know he's like down Maury Smith.
A couple of terms.
Problem was Maury Smith has
a very good defensive guard,
high level recovery and like he
doesn't really attack cardio.
He's also working with you
work with Frank Shamrock,
first friends with shamrock.
He was also an easy two 30 like
just a natural Django land.
He actually played locked down too.
Yeah. Yeah, he did. Yeah. Look,
Maury Smith is a smart guy and his,
his kickboxing was so high level man when
he started fighting these MMA fighters
and they realized that he could
defend himself off of his back,
but if you're standing up with
him, you're just fucked man. Yeah.
The problem was Mark Coleman wasn't never
really worked on is guard passing back
then. You know what I mean? He just,
he just assumed that when
you take someone down,
you just get on top of them
and beat the shit out of him.
But that's true if you
don't have any kind of card.
But Maurice Smith had a professional
defensive guard. Yeah. Yeah.
And also this is the headbutt
days. I was headbutt days. Yeah.
Yeah. When I don't think they feel
different. They aren't gloves.
You would over hook here. They has loves,
right? Oh yeah, they definitely had kick.
Do you remember the gut,
the guard,
the most important guard position when
there's headbutts are allowed? Grabbed,
grabbed the back of the
head? No. Did he won
when I've got sidekick or the
fully straight to the gut. Damn.
He's a nice man. He's got some
great fights in the UFC. Man.
John Jones dropped Vito Belfort with
the front leg side kick one off,
some amazing, I'd never seen that.
It was a front leg side kick.
One of the most underrated kicks.
People just don't do it that good.
Do you think v two or bell force
cage side tonight with chucked him,
rushes the cage and says, uh, I
wouldn't fight both you pussies,
but he's just fucking juice to
the gills. And we're like, yeah,
it probably will happen. They'd let
them if the UFC let them go over there,
if they load the right,
I've been Dana.
Well it and they'll put,
they'll have him too, you know,
if they just got to regulate medications,
make sure that everything's okay.
Come on.
I mean if they're testing chuck and Tito,
you gotta Test v Torque ticket.
Can't beat your campaign.
Kelly, let's not do that. Okay,
well it's only having five and like,
let's get me on an Indian reservation.
It was this, I don't want anyone
70 what's happening? Yeah.
Is a lightweight one seven
years, dude. How about Walter?
Wherever Hudson Nibia virtue.
Neil magnesium and he looked really,
maybe it was a real problem.
He looks really good. Good
man. He looks really good.
Maggie, I don't know if it's
the jet lag or why he's my boy,
but he was a late start and he had eight
the fuck up. Yeah. He got chewed up.
You got chewed up, poked in the
eye like early in the first round.
Then he just couldn't decide like depth.
He had no idea what to do.
So he's just always like waiting room.
That's a real problem. And you know they,
there is a solution in the works.
I can't talk about it. I'm a proxy.
I pokes goggles. Yeah,
no they fell. It's there.
But I have a better glove design that
they're working on it. But someone
said to try and kick,
oh hands dude.
I also heard they're doing something
about a room or is the super room right
star anything. You saw it in
2009 I'd be like permanently,
really boom,
leave that side kick to the
body and then nasty left hands.
You mean they might get rid of you sat
and we're back to old days. It's crazy.
I don't know if they were getting
rid of it. Maybe a little.
That is so crazy.
Sidekick to the body,
but especially the way he threw it.
I mean he really got his weight behind it.
You could fuck people up with
that man set of lips on them.
It's like we all accept that the front
leg side or the turning side kick or
spinning back kick, we all accept
that puts people out. Right.
Well how much harder is you're turning
side kicked in your front leg side kick
way harder. Yeah, but significantly.
But how much does it take really to make
your body cave in? Because my front leg,
sorry, is way harder than
my left hook. Way Harder.
Your front foot front lakeside.
Really? So yeah. So if you,
if you think like of course you can left,
took someone in the body and
dropped them and fuck them up bad,
he hit him and liver.
Right?
Well why wouldn't you to think that you
could do that also with the front leg
side kick on a regular basis.
Yeah.
He's got to have a quicker snap to it
takes what most a long time to develop.
That's the prize it takes.
You got to develop that quick snap
and that's what most guys are missing.
Most guys that comes out to slow the body,
the body's about is more designed for
I left hook that you can keep the power
and yet I fuck probably till you're in
your sixties versus from from Thai kick
is an athletic move. Touch the state is
definitely no headway to kick that much.
No.
Well it's really definitely a con a
little bit but not like great is some fit
kit is a good kicker. Yeah.
Yeah. But nothing like crazy. No,
nothing like a cro cop type character.
Huh? There's no one in the, uh,
there's no one in the UFC for the big
guys. There's really not. That's a kicker.
Who else? Well, this must be
someone we're not thinking of.
Marcin Tibora kicks a lot,
but he's not like a stadium kids.
Not like a heavyweight. Barboza there's
no like just monster with the kids.
Yeah. I was hoping that was going to be
a something we would acquire it. Right.
Like get some sort of Rico
Verhoeven type character. Yeah.
Kathy's fighting MMA and he's trained
at Aka well listen, standup wise for,
he's on not just one level but so
many levels above most people in MMA.
Rachel for Hoover in,
it's a mine as far as strict up,
but that doesn't always
tremble. It doesn't translate
now. It doesn't translate.
You gotta have you gotta like the distance
is different. The timing, your stance.
Verhoeven is something special.
And he's a, he's a big giant guy.
Have you ever seen right now crazy
because he had obviously a Dutch guy,
giant milk fed Dejak Sadie.
Really? Yeah, he's uh,
he's about 240 plus pounds
and the guy has mad cardio.
It's one of the crazy things about him.
He puts a crazy pace on these
guys and he's a striker.
Have you seen some of his MMA fights? No.
Who the fuck is finding that poor soul?
I mean, he just area have mercy. You
want some of that be fuck is going on.
So I'm like, yeah, see if you
can find out. Oh, I mean I'd use,
I'd have to use my kicks dude.
And he's like, hey, hey, be,
and he's got an AK training
with DC. Hey guys, I've sparked.
Oh Bro, what the fuck are
you showing us, Jamie?
Don't put it out by three is boy,
he's like a giant Dutchman to
try and find a highlight reel.
Final highlight reel. Wow. He's a monster
dude. Oh my Lord. And great hair too.
And he's a young guy who's fine.
I mean,
I don't even know if all
behind that survived two beats
of the best in the world.
If all the guy, nothing. You
guys not having big contract,
my uncle now you can take a beating.
Now that big guy is supposed
to be super tough for sure.
It looks at people like that kind of shit.
You know,
it's like oof capable of when
big Roy wins by knockout.
They trust.
Yes,
they do look at that and it weird
like I must do fucking tons of cardio,
but he just, the gut just stay.
Just ate the wrong food, Bro.
Look at that fucking Combo.
But look at his kicks man.
I mean Ricoh over who don't
go to go to his MMA fight.
Some guy gets fucking starched and you,
you can't, he's not finding experienced,
wait, wait, what are you doing? What
are you doing? Who's running this shit?
Then you can't listen. I'm all over
the place. Jamie kicks herself.
You want to try to watch some of this
stuff? Knees kicks. Oh, Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ is right.
How old is he?
I don't even think he's 30 17 boom.
He's 15 years old.
If I had no, he's Dutch.
15 if I had to guess,
I would say he's like 29 how old is he?
Stays in his thirties yep. Can't check it.
That's it. The tallest
people in the world, right?
They're the biggest people in the world
in general. Are they the giant people?
I don't know if they're the biggest
people in the world, but they add heard.
They're the tallest people in the world.
Dude,
I'd love to see him and Alistair Overeem.
Go on
a big boy.
I wish she would take them down for sure.
The officers are very good grappling that
Alister would definitely stand up with
them for a little bit, for sure. Which
is what he does, but he would uh,
take them down. Alster very underrated
grappler. Oh, amazing grappler. Yeah.
And it's grounded. Pam will fuck
you up. It's a real problem.
It's used. Don't feel as guilty for
a little bit. Yeah. And it's also,
he's just had so many more MMA fights
deciding for a hundred years. Yeah.
He's good at everything. But
Verhoeven was it. He has it.
He has an advantage over basically
everything. Now in heavyweight,
Saki has that smooth bill too, where
you just like, you know what? Oh my God,
I get it. But what's interesting is Saki,
what is he fighting? One 85 in the UFC.
Yeah, but you should be at one
80 fiber. Yeah, that's, yeah.
That's what it is, right? Yeah. He
should be finding five. What's that bro?
29 29 years old.
29 years old.
He in the UFC yet or no, no, no.
He's making his way through, you
know, smaller organizations was,
so show me one of his MMA fights. Holy
Shit. He fights on her ma. Yes Bro.
Some poor soul whose
fighting him? Rico. Rico.
Verhoeven. Verhoeven is a real problem
and he's training with Cain and what?
DEVINCI heavyweight. Why every bit of
huge dude. I mean he's like six, four.
You better get that Jujitsu. He's about
six [inaudible] four. He's a big boy.
Big Boy. Big Boy. And two 40 jacked.
Don't let this go a natural shape.
Maybe. Yeah, maybe not. Yeah,
maybe. Right. Maybe Stryker's come.
It's wait and see what happens at
Jujitsu together. Oh, for sure.
Right? Yeah. What do you
think is happening? Uh, again,
Broomer on super dark
web. Rumor is that, uh,
there's gonna be a change with
Usada moving forward a little bit.
Is this him, Jamie and this
video, the other video.
Oh Shit. He took the guy down. Nice. Maybe
he's good at Jujitsu. He's an athlete.
Holy Shit. All the body. Oh Shit.
Did you do not want that guy on top of
you growing up? County looks like in here.
It looks like, who knows?
Maybe he's really good on the
ground. Show me that again,
Jamie. Show me the beginning part of
it again. This has been a while ago.
If done inside MMA.
Cool.
I feel like
he's still doing that high cover up.
What's your obviously worked though,
man. He had to take the dude down.
Yeah, that was a wild little exchange.
I mean that dude did not, uh, I mean
they came to throw at each other. They,
that guy was not avoiding them.
I like how he's punching the
records from the mail. Oh, does that
fighty starch so hard man.
He could hit you said whenever you get a
real striker on top of, you know, that's,
it actually could turned their hips.
The forest.
Do you remember when a cro cop got on
top of Gabriel Gonzaga? The rematch.
The revenge fight. Elbows smashed
him with elbows. They were horrific.
Horrific. And then who did dank? Gabriel
got good with elbows from the bottom.
Didn't he fuck somebody up
from the bottom? Look in,
look at the euro February
in his corner there.
Here it is. This is, this is more, more.
It's the same one or the video is
more recent. This is Rico Verhoeven.
This looks like the same fight,
isn't it?
I think different than how
many have you had? Is it Jane?
That looks like the sense of I don't
how it'd be done. This is the same. Yes.
I've got it for a kickboxer
not bad passing. Yeah.
I mean he's got to learn,
right? Hi. He's also smart.
So like what got him to become an elite
kickboxer that kind of intelligence as
well as hard work.
He's just going to translate that to MMA.
He's just got to make sure that
he fixes the holes in his game.
Is that the right king of risk?
And he likes to tease out the
right Kay Kay with the wrestlers.
Like these are hard fucking punches,
man.
Get this clean and room for your body.
Just lifting a leg up.
I think only one time ever.
Maybe twice have some,
someone got knocked out.
Wow.
There were a while there were mounting
somebody from the bottom. Really?
You're saying the guy on mount got
knocked up, somebody catches up. Yeah.
It's happened maybe twice in Paris.
I want to keep getting knocked out
while you're being mounted. I mean,
not while you're mounted.
Sorry. Excuse me.
I think Duane Ludwig and when did it,
wasn't that something that
who
it happened in? In Japan? Yeah. Oh Man.
I'm trying to remember this. Hello?
Dwayne load weights. Fight. Yeah.
Why don't I feel like Duane
Ludwig Dude. Oh, Eve Edwards.
Duane Ludwig did it to eve Edwards.
He heard him like really bad and
eve like covered it up and he was,
yeah,
he was on top and Dwayne punched or from
the bottom and hurt them really bad.
He talked about it on the
podcast. Now I remember, dude,
how long has this fight taken to dear
to this point? What's going on here?
You feel like, well, they're a,
they're in China, so we're there at,
maybe they're just giving us chance
to settle in. Isn't it weird though,
isn't just China's Communist,
right?
That's not really, not really. No, not
really. We're a capitalist country there.
Are there a command economy though?
Like so where a lot of the decisions
are made by the poet bureau, by the,
by the actual government,
and then from there their flag looks
like the Soviet Union flag. Yeah.
Well if Chad, it's still
red China, right. It was,
there was a communist revolution. Not
Anymore though. It's weird. That is,
it's not dang shop democracy right now.
You know when I went to new Asian,
uh, for Abu Dhabi and in the hotels, boom,
they have the TV on with the, with
the propaganda. Oh yeah. How long ago?
Your tone talking shit on the
United States. Really? Yeah.
There it's a documentary that's on,
you know,
it's the default setting on your
TVs and in Beijing. Fuck them.
Get there.
You sit down to watch TV and a documentary
on how bad the United is is playing.
This
is, this is why we're doing what we're
doing. Look at the amount of Shelby Cobra.
The United States is uh,
you know,
they're just going down,
down the list of all the,
the things that the United
States does that uh,
when you go there for mental to society,
did you have to do your fingerprints
on the machine? You have to get,
you get all your fingerprints are
recorded and then you're given,
at least when I was shooting a movie, you
were given a our adjuster, right? Yeah.
You were given a memo to say if
you and no political dissent,
like you will not voice your political
point of view of it's contrary to the
government's live. I don't know why. If
you do that, you'll be asked to leave.
Or You could be some American
kid like try and steal something.
Oh yeah. That was balls.
A son [inaudible] son,
Ucla basketball teams stole like some
sunglasses and fucking Trump had to help
get them out. They don't fuck
around Chinese super fucked. Ooh.
But Dang shall Pang said
famously to be rich is glorious,
which was so contrary to
the communist metallurgical.
It's cool as fuck the UFC in there, so
it can't be that. It's a huge market.
Everybody wants the Chinese market. Well,
that's the next big push for the UFC.
Right? I mean internationally, they're
growing like you're not getting Google.
You know when we tried,
well you'd have to keep trying
to find servers that would,
that would provide Google and the Internet
in China because they can't get you
to the access of everything. Yes. And then
they find you and they shut that down.
And then you've got to find another one.
So anybody who worked on the set,
who anybody worked on a set couldn't
get w you're given a phone there.
So when I was an actor, I was
given a phone with WeChat. Fine.
It's a phone issue to
me that I can use there.
I can't use technically my phone
and link into the worldwide web.
Too many firewalls. Yeah,
they you, and then by the way,
if you want to use your phone,
you download something called Wechat,
which is an APP which you know,
is controlled by somebody.
So it's,
there's a lot of group think there's zero,
there's zero descent.
And if you say something derogatory
about the government's appear like the,
and something like Weechat, they
probably monitor it. Jesus, man, fuck.
They Monitor. But of course they monitor.
Of course they do. You didn't text me.
It's an amazing example of how
you can control a lot of people.
But you know in north North Korea you
don't even, there is no Internet, correct?
No, no, it's good. They get
no internet, no TV channels.
I talked to a friend of mine works for
the government and his wife works for the
government too and they had
to go to Russia for something
and he said they were,
you were told just absolutely think
you're being followed everywhere you go.
Assumed they're listening to every
word you say. Assume that your,
your hotel rooms bugged. Yup. And then
where you go, you're being followed.
It's all right.
It's kind of like the states.
More evidence we chat is recording private
messages for Beijing to spy on users.
Did you even use the phone? Really be
not real. You text me every now and then.
Tell me how bad is happening already
for a while. Don't we already know that?
They're like, yeah, everything
that's just confirmed like that,
it just freaks people out
as well. It should, but you
know, we're, we're just, we,
we forgot how this is.
Why freedom of expression and freedom of
speech in this country is so important
because while this is happening here
in the United States and and freedom of
speech is, you know, something that
it, it gets up for debate sometimes.
It's like who gets to decide?
Who gets to say this and gets to
say that and what should we stop?
The problem with any kind
of censorship is right.
While we're here being able
to talk shit on the podcast,
there are a big giant spots of the world
filled with billions of people that
can't do this. If they did this,
they would get arrested. Locked up.
That's exactly right.
Deja Vu. China Theater.
We did podcasts the way we do podcasts.
No fucking chance. The Arab world,
I mean one of the things that will
come out my legs and in the United Arab
Emirates and Qatar and what,
what,
what's come out is that these
governments are saying these, these, the,
the royal family and the people
that are in power, they go, well,
there's political dissent.
So you've got journalists or people
have formed groups at for say,
let's say democracy or
elections, and guess what? Uh,
they hire American mercenaries. It was
just a whole article, blackwater dude,
guys like that.
They find hire American horse needs to
take care of their terrorist problem and
they're terrorist problem that they get.
As long as the American company gets
issued weaponry and orders from the
standing army, then they can do
whatever they want to use this.
And so this all came, who was the
article I just read? It was fascinating.
It was a New York Times,
but it was just exposed where there
were these ex Badass special forces guys
making a fortune,
essentially acting as mercenaries in
countries like the United Arab Emirates,
et Cetera,
to get rid of their terrorist problem.
Now that's the royal family saying it's
a terrorist problem when it could very
well be just a political group, but
they're getting killed. It's terrible. So,
you know,
but the bigger issue in this country is
apparently from what I'm seeing in my
own experience is that when you put
a certain ad on Facebook and Facebook
decides to,
that ad might be offensive to someone.
My count just got flagged. Yeah. Uh, okay.
And so even if you say get in the best
shape of your life or whatever it might
be, that might make other people feel
uncomfortable for whatever reason,
it's either a Bot,
an algorithm or somebody is flagging
that ad or shutting down your account.
And I know a number of people
that that's happened too. Huh?
So what the fuck is going on there?
But, but you know also too is if,
let's say you do an ad or you do
a post on Instagram, let's see,
you have 2 million followers on
how many you have. Let's see,
you have 60 million and you do a post,
you know,
they limit to how many people that reach
is now you have to pay extra to make
sure it reads the Gaa. People Facebook.
Cause that's when those up to,
so I says promote your posts. Like
why I fucking sick. That's why. Yeah.
That seems like a business model,
but hold on, but is it here?
Yeah,
it's kind of smart.
Yeah. Right person, let's say it's
more, doesn't mean it's not fucked up.
One of those fitness people that grow
their Instagram by just putting ass.
Very not.
There's dudes too.
There's guys that I followed that are
just like super jacked and they're doing
like one arm chin ups and Shit and you
fall flips. Yeah. Following fitness, dude,
settle down, man. Take
it. He's comfortable.
They're always in a gym where they
can work out shirtless shot, right.
Everyone's shirtless,
but they're doing an impressive shit.
There's like a bunch of them
that I follow them. Okay,
but where are you sitting on my point?
You made me nervous having know about
posts, man. They'll reach all these extra
people there. Their thing will grow,
their business will grow.
I'm a man that I'm a fan of that what?
I'm not a fan of investment. Why would
I have a question about is is there a,
some buddy in charge of what's,
what's permissible and what's
not according to a certain
code of conduct and do
they have a political agenda?
So in other words,
so if I put out something
that has profanity or maybe
I'll stand up clip where I
want to get people in,
it's,
it's a clip that is offensive to said
person touch possibilities. They can go,
nope. Flag stopping them from
doing that. Well, but see with uh,
with the dudes with their
shirts off flex and shit,
when they're trying to get clients,
that's fine. And they can promote,
reach other people outside their
followers isn't what it should be.
But if you have 100,000 followers,
it should reach all hundred thousand.
That's what's crazy to me. Yeah.
They're going to lose everybody.
There's going to be a new Instagram.
If they started doing that shit and he
gets out of hand, people just leave.
Well there's,
you know,
it's shadow banning is right know
there's a concept of shadow banning and I
don't know if this is, Jamie would be
able to speak to this better than me.
Is that ever been proved
that they actually do shadow
ban people? What's that?
Or is that it's they used is that if you
say we're on Twitter and maybe you were
conservative and you said a lot of rude
things about liberals that maybe they
would decide that although it
doesn't violate the terms of service,
what you do is, uh,
makes them uncomfortable.
They make a moral judgment and they
decide to limit your engaged match.
I'm talking about, yeah, this is
somehow possible. Possible. Right.
Or is that like a hater?
It's up in what you're saying
with the paying of, of post to,
it happens similarly there too.
If you were at an account that never paid.
Yeah. And once you pay, once
you give him five bucks, you're,
you're like flag now as an account
that will pay and changing the game on
Twitter. It's Twitter. You don't cross the
board. Yeah. You can pay on Twitter too.
How do you pay on Twitter? Do you
pay on Twitter? You don't have to,
but the option you can
pay. Yeah, promoted tweets.
It's a promoted tweet.
The top trending topic for the
last year or two is a paid,
it says paid or promoted.
Yeah.
You just have to go into it
because they get money now.
That's how they're banned from
Twitter. A lot of people, man, really
management's been banned from Twitter
and more conservatives, conservatives,
but liberals like Ben to do,
liberals that are put out death threats,
they'd been banned.
But general you get should be lopsided.
You don't know. That's a good question.
We should find out what is the,
what is the suffering should be banned?
The backing band.
That's a good question too.
Is it to incite violence?
The violate their terms of service
and definitely if you incite violence,
that's definitely a no, no
racial slurs or no, no racist.
Fuckhead you can call someone a fuck head,
but you can't call him like a
Guinea fuckhead. Yeah. There's like,
there's certain things you can say
in certain things you can't say,
but it's a lot of, it's subjective. Yeah.
But then some of it's pretty black
and white. Like if you're like, man,
I want to go so much a blow
up that fucking school.
Fuck those cards. Of course.
Where the racist stuff.
Yeah. Yes. All of that.
I think you got to regulate the hate to,
if it's just bullying and shit like
that, just ban them. Wow. It's like,
here's the question and this is who gets
to decide who was hateful and what's
not,
and then the problem is they keep pushing
it further and further and further and
then even just insults or hateful.
Even even like this guy who's a dumb ass.
Yeah, that's hateful. Saying
someone's a dumb ass. It's hateful.
I mean they're kind of,
there's only so far you can,
you could keep going down that road,
right?
You want to make sure that you have
free expression and you don't get free
expression.
If you banned people from saying things
that just don't seem that bad to me.
Looks Jones, you think his banning
would like to see what he says.
Sandy Hook stuff it sandy, but see, but
here's the thing. Getting sued for that.
Anyway. Here's the thing. Yeah. He
was already getting sued for that.
Like what did he say that got them?
I think something happened that he did
had nothing to do with even what he said.
He confronted them at some event,
right? And he was yelling in the back.
And that happened after he confronted
people in Congress and he's got a bus.
Alex Jones has a regular
on a former CIA officer,
Dr Steve [inaudible].
He has them on like once every six months.
That's where he got the sandy
hook information was from him.
That dude is on volume as a
CIA guy know about sandy hook.
The fuck would he know that's the dumbest
fucking thing that Alex Jones has ever
done. It's also a moral
and there's parents, fuck,
fuck that guy. Fuck of whatever.
If he said it didn't fuck him too,
you have to always wonder
and you would you, I mean,
I'm not making any accusations,
but you'd have to always wonder
when you hear a story like that,
why would someone say
something so ridiculous?
And why would someone tried to convince
someone like Alex Jones of something so
ridiculous? And I think there'd be
two reasons. One to discredit Jones.
If you could talk him into
repeating what you said,
if you think he's willing to do,
that's interesting.
You can easily discredit him and it
would be a really good way to do it.
Like the best way to do it. That's what
I'm saying, whether he's right or wrong,
but
whether he's right or wrong
several times on the show.
So, but he's started Alex
for Alex to believe him. No,
it's not that crazy.
He's hearing it from a guy who
was in the CIA started like this.
It's not that crazy for him to
believe in a guide from, you know,
he may or may not be right. But it
started with Alex actually saying, uh, uh,
he said, unfortunately he goes
something to the effect of I saw it,
it was very sad.
And then,
but unfortunately I've seen a lot of soap
operas and I've seen a lot of, and, and,
and I know an actor when I see one and
that's where it started with him. Yes.
And he's being,
he's being sued by,
he bought a farm in Connecticut and
he's in trouble. Be Good acting coach,
but remembering chosen activities.
He was me in court and they said,
what the fuck? Basically what the
fuck you're doing? He goes, listen,
I say a lot of things just for,
for entertainment of course,
like it's just for the during.
Is that his trial with his wife?
But he did admit, he's like, uh,
I don't believe it. A lot of it.
I just say he's got a business.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing about all a lot
of nutrition people and he's right.
A lot of these people is you make money.
You make money in this, in this business,
and whether what or whatever it is,
whether it's being a political pundit,
whether it's on an exercise guy,
you make money having answers.
If you're somebody who's more scientific
and says, I dunno, it depends.
Maybe you're not going to make money.
When you say bone broth cures cancer,
you're going to sell
books. When you say, uh,
my plant based Diet is proven to
do blah, blah, blah, whatever,
you're going to make money.
If you say, I'm going to,
I'll help you lose weight and
keep it off in four months,
you're not going to say,
Hey, I'm a nutritionist guy.
It's going to take you two years.
We're going to try to change how you're
going to have bounce backs are going to
have plateaus and being realistic.
Yeah. Nobody's going to buy that shit.
Just you're Dong guy has all
movement, man. So, but with, uh,
with Alex Jones, so is he banned for life
or business? I don't know. Well, I mean,
he's still has his website. He's got a
big loss to just kind of worry about,
but it shows they got rid of his show
helping all the farmers and shit. No,
the only thing that had happened is
they pulled him off of youtube and they
pulled him off of Twitter and Facebook
to an iTunes and iTunes and he's got a
major lawsuit with a walker and that
doesn't compromise. There's tears.
There's two guys, there's two guys
that are being sued over that. Uh,
Alex Jones and a guy named a wolf gang.
Helbig great.
He's also, he's also being sued, that guy,
his job was to prepare
schools for school shootings.
So he came out and he started saying
that too. So He's, he's breaking apart.
He started saying that he's getting,
he's getting sued along with
Alex Jones. Oh my God. Well,
but they didn't show up for when you
went to court. They'd never showed up.
So they dropped the case.
What about one thing about the La law,
it's kind of weird now
that they're the parents.
Why would sandy hook be fake? Let's
not talk about this stuff. Oh, I dunno.
I find it fascinating.
Well, why in the world would it be
faked be, I know you get riled up.
Like what's the conspiracy theories? Zero
zero thoughts that it, that it's fake.
But I do have thoughts on why someone
would try to get other people to say it's
fake. And this, if there's any,
does anything that's ever going to
convince you that conspiracy theories are
stupid?
It's making up a fake conspiracy easily.
Provable,
fake conspiracy about a real tragedy.
That's a nice,
simple psychological
way to discredit people.
If I thought you were a dumb
ass but you had a big voice,
I might talk you into saying some shit
about something that's not real and have
you convinced it's real. So you spout
it out, you look a moron, right?
And that discredits everything
else you said. It's right.
And you have to be really careful
with a lot of these stories.
There's a lot of these,
these conspiracy theories that
literally start out a joke.
They start out in four Chan and a lot
of these chat rooms as trolls and then
before you know it,
it becomes a real thing cause his head
over and as I said over and over again,
and then morons get ahold of. But it's
true though, right? Like he's a smart,
we can all agree he's a, I don't agree.
What do you mean is you don't think he's,
I don't know to do what he's doing.
Listen, I don't ever talk about stuff.
No, you would not say he's
a dumb person. I don't know.
I can't speak for you. I take it,
yeah, he's not stupid. It's, I'm very,
very sad that he said that Sandy Hook
isn't real, but I fuck with them.
But I always enjoy being around that guy.
You would say he's articulate smart guy.
Right? I see he's a fun guy to yeah,
so I'm just saying for him to,
it's not like you can just honey
dick and back dude. Sandy Hook.
Like it would have to be something you
need. Loves conspiracies, man. You know,
he really does.
And this is the problem with someone
who likes hunts out conspiracies.
You're going to love them. You're
gonna, you're gonna look for them.
Numerology and the Bible.
You can find any pattern.
This is the problem is when you have
a vested interest in them being real,
when it's your business, because
there are a lot of them that are real.
So the problem is if you have a vested
interest in them being real and you
exclude information that would point
to them not being real and you use
confirmation bias and you fuck up and
then you try to convince other people that
you're correct. This is something
that people will fall down.
I'd love to hear you super
quiet about all this,
but if you're a conspiracy theory,
which ones have been proven correct? Oh,
that many, right? There's plenty like,
absolutely. There's big ones like Enron,
you know there's big ones.
There's big ones. You know,
there's a many documentaries and books
have been written on the Enron conspiracy.
These guys got together and they figured
out how to make a kajillion dollars and
fuck people over. And it was, it was,
it was breaking the law and they
knew it was breaking the law.
They can aspire to do it and by mediums
and forums so you can take, take them.
There's wise people to think the 2008
hires, housing crisis, that that was the,
that was all on purpose and these
guys built this bubble up and sank it.
Proven though it's not
proven. It's not proven. The
bubble,
the housing bubble was,
they've been great books written on a
basketball with Michael Lewis's book.
The big short is a good book on it.
Good. Yeah. But they, you know, there,
there's been a lot of research on that.
Too many banks. Is there any approval?
One turn all that is all it all
depends. Brennan describes, no,
not at all. No. And he knows his shit.
It all depends on how much
circumstantial evidence, uh,
makes you throw up some red flags.
Like some people they just don't see the
red flags and some people are red flags
go up right away. So it all depends. Like
when you say is there any proof? Well, um,
you don't need a, I mean at, at us,
at a certain point when you
have circumstantial evidence,
at a certain point it adds up.
You know, you know, if, if, um,
one case pretty suspect
JFK suspect is fuck super,
there's no book, Jeff K's a
perfect example, right? Yeah.
There's no actual proof of the
conspiracy that there was, uh, you know,
multiple shooters or the CIA and the mob.
There's no actual proof, but there's a
lot of circumstantial evidence as well.
So it all depends on,
it all depends on how much circumstantial
evidence do you need for any
particular conspiracy theory where you go,
Oh shit,
there's enough circumstantial evidence.
Like, if there was a murder, right,
and you were being accused and
only one person said, you know,
I saw Brendan like four blocks away
from the restaurant where his friend was
killed. If just that one person, sorry,
that's one piece of
circumstantial evidence. That's
not enough to convict you.
But if a hundred people said they saw
you two blocks away in the parking lot,
none of it alone, none of it's
standing alone will put you in jail.
But at a certain point, enough
circumstantial evidence,
we'll put dudes in jail.
Or if enough people tell the
same story about you with Cosby,
it was the same story over and over.
It's like not all of these women can't
be there all telling the exact same story
about the same Emma Jackson.
Well, not only that caused me,
had gone to court and had a lawsuit
sealed. Right. And paid a woman off.
That's right. I get it. Already
been done. So that, yeah,
so this was a part of the whole thing
was that he had to come out and uh,
you know the, the headed defend that in
his most recent trial Bill Clinton too.
I just got done watching those
Monica Lewinsky tapes. Yeah.
Bill Clinton was a freak.
Oh yeah dude.
The other problem with like being like
Alex Jones who makes a lot of money,
office conspiracies and things
is that once he said something,
I know a pretty good fan of his Alex.
And um,
what the problem is once you say something
and you have that big of a following,
right? So let's just say
you float out of conspiracy,
but then you look at evidence,
you start to realize,
maybe I overstepped my bounds,
we all say things we wish we had and our,
we all say things.
But now you've got a whole movement behind
what you said now to try to pull back
would turn that 25% of the whoever it is
against you and that can be a liability
to two.
So one of the things about being a
public figure as you can say something,
and if you're selling product
and sell on your show on that,
you better be all in. You've
gotta stay all in. Yeah.
So you become a prisoner to your own
kind of first impulse or own first. Sort
of like a matter of how it, well, it's,
especially if he's also an entertainer.
It's also
this rush to say you'd know something
when you don't know it. Yeah.
There's a rush to say there's a rush to
say we, we absolutely know this happened.
We absolutely know that happened.
Attainment. They're getting it
from somewhere. He has his sources.
She's got information on on
these, on these, you know,
these tragic events or something like
that. Or you don't think there'll be,
I just looking at me and Brandon,
listen,
I think he has some people that sell
drones. No, I'm not. Don't take the bait.
And Eddie, he's floating a fucking
huge worm out. Hey, listen,
come on the show and try not to
talk about conspiracy theories,
but I always get sucked back into the,
I always get sucked back to he spoke
that word. No, look, look, he's,
they're legit question.
I don't know.
You're asking super crazy legit questions.
You're asking,
you're asking detection. Someone that
someone, you know with one eye opened up,
kind of like,
okay,
Hey Brian,
so I'm not bringing up,
let's talk about tidies
it say no more fam.
I was biting my tongue just like,
I'm not asking you to go down the crazy,
you know,
and Telsia cause I'm just saying, how do
you get there? You know what I'm saying?
So he has his black belt in
conspiracy theories. Bryan, you know,
he just never brides in say that there
are no black belts and conspiracy
theories. Alex Jones
says, hold my beer. And
it was quick. All right, now
the gone where we're waiting.
What is this hot field sign?
Joe's Camaros, man. Ooh, that's his fight.
I love this has been gone for a hot
second, right? It was this last one,
Damien Maia, I believe. Think
so. And that was a bad one, man.
I did not like the way they pulled him
off of mines back. That made me angry.
I might have that. He was standing
up and wrapped around the referees,
separated them, and I was
like, what are you doing?
Do you know how hard it is for him to get
to that position and the best grappler
on fucking plan? What are you doing
as a bat? He's a really good spot.
They're both pretty dry. [inaudible]
energy. Yeah, some bullshit bullshit.
Damien Maia. Well, it's fucked up,
man. It's like that is fighting. Okay.
He's fighting right now.
Just because it's not exciting enough.
No, they're fighting you. Fuck. This
is what they're doing. The grammy,
me people that freak out
about it like you. You got to.
Just because it's so
exciting when it's good.
They want it to be exciting all the time,
but it can't be,
there's going to be fights
where to to fight correctly.
They have to fight in a way
that's not as entertainment.
It's not as entertaining, but it's the
right way to fight, but you can't sleep.
You can't find the right way.
Exactly.
You can't not fight the right way just
because it's more interesting for people
that don't understand what's,
how you become a 500 fighters.
You when one punishment we should take.
It's just not the way to fight. You never
gets the bow ever, ever. Or if you do,
you don't keep it. It's very rare.
Who sponsor a beast? Man. Super tough.
Super strong guy like
wrestling fighting today.
No, I wish. No, it's fine.
Dos Anjos though. That's a
great fight. It's heavy man.
That's a heavy fight. Design. Just have
to 70 just became a fucking beef. Yeah,
but he didn't look that good against um,
uh,
our boy Colby Covington. No,
Colby put on that pressure.
That crazy pills.
Colby beat his ass,
but now they announced Colby Woodley.
Of course you have to have that.
That's the fight.
I don't,
Woodley doesn't want to have it because
he's probably angry at the dude. Dude.
I wish I had done Colby.
Ben Ask him.
You're going to see angry Tyron
Woodley versus Colby Covington.
That's going to be very
interesting. Angry. I want to
fuck you up. Tyron Woodley.
What'd they say? Nightmare. Nightmare.
Think about the fucking
guys he's fought recently,
whether it's Darren tail or Thompson.
Both guys known to be
really high level strikers.
He dropped both those guys didn't hit him.
Oh yeah.
Damien Maia. Perfect game plans
and tagged him a few times.
He hit him with some decent shit.
He's brought but not the right tire
and hit him. Hit Tyron, fucked him up,
and he drops humped in both fights. And
then Dan until he knocked out. Well,
he got to dumb. He dropped him and then
he choked him. Fucking rocked him. Yeah.
Yeah. He dropped drawn. Any a
member. Yes. Yeah, that's right.
And he didn't know what was coming.
It was so weird.
It was like it'd be probably had been
rattled by all those punches and elbows
and shit on the ground too.
And he got dropped by a super clean punch.
Beautiful counter.
Right.
Do you know there's a fight
for like nine weeks in a row,
which I'm not mad at at all.
Look at this weird to be TBD.
Tbd Tobacco because the heavyweights,
the tough heavyweight final, Oh,
I've been watching tough heavyweight.
It's actually a tough
woman's featherweight final.
This is the last tough.
No,
no.
They're handling strike you back for a
second thing I'd ever think they were
thinking it was the last season.
Right? Well, when you say really well,
Dana said it makes money. J says
it does. No one's watching it.
I don't know if that's true.
How dare because of those,
it's hard to tell like when someone just
watches something in the moment, right?
Like when they have ratings, because
almost everybody DVR shit. Now,
especially when you
talk about cable shows,
it is a fact when they're talking
about the numbers that they get,
that shit is Voodoo. All
right? If you get a number,
like say if you put up a youtube
video and it gets a million hits,
that's a million hits. We know for a fact
that's a fact. That's a million heads.
We don't know how many
people it is because some,
some people will watch
it five or six times.
I still believe that when they're doing
like Nielsen ratings, Shit that's viewed.
Dude,
low
numbers low. Now they're all
sun. Yeah, no, it's no phones.
We know that shit is DVR.
Now what they do is,
cause I know this from my show now
what they do is they will do Nielsen,
but then they will look at like three
days. Do you watch it in three days?
Do you watch it the seven days? You know,
they have all these different metrics.
The metrics still coming from them having
to fill out forms or is it something
more? It's more technologically based now,
but it's still not a, it's not, you know,
you're still dealing with a number of
those weird definitely doesn't tell you
shit. I find that so strange.
They don't tell you nothing.
I don't want to give you, the power
will just flip. How fucked up is that?
Because if let's say 30 million people
watched your special and like, hey man,
we're just gonna run it back. The same
thing as last year. You're like, what?
Because you can really look
and go in and renegotiate and,
but they're very generous. Yeah.
Maybe they're very generous.
I'm telling you. They're very generous.
No, I know they paid you well, but I'm,
hey everybody. Well, when did they
start allowing nudity on Youtube?
Is that new or is there a
rude real you talking about?
You talking about red? No,
no, no. I'm talking about you.
What the fuck is watching you pour
hot naked chicks really
about to get a virus.
Youtube on Youtube
telling you, man, you can watch naked
chicks on UTA. It's legal now. Come on.
I don't think so. Addie, where
did you uh, try us the other day?
I'm on Youtube.
I'm like hot naked chicks.
I want her to see how much can you see?
Are you seeing this is just
testing it out. I'm like,
I wonder if porn is making an onto youtube
and I went hot naked chicks and there
are videos. I'm doing it right now.
Seriously. Isn't that weird that you know,
like we'll make a distinction between top
lizard bottom on. Slick topless. Yeah.
It's kind of racy, but bottom was, oh
God, yeah, you're showing pussy. Yeah.
What are you doing? Yeah. Is everybody
here going to the Tyson purified?
I get to work. I'm not. Is
that the one in December? Yes.
It wasn't that Tyson fury. Fucking
wild. Comfort of my own home,
sir. It's like this feed up
freed up, perhaps cocktail.
This is how I'm going to watch
apps and then if I have to Poop,
I'm going to pause it.
Why Shit.
And I'm not going to look at my
phone so I'm not gonna have any idea.
Maybe will happen. Let's do it at Joe's
house. Dude, I'm working. I'm in New York.
Are you? Are you going? You can come
over. I can get you tickets, I'm sure.
All right. Hey listen. Brian
needs tickets. Tickets.
You really want to go there in
person. Maybe. I don't know.
It seems like a lot of people I'd rather
look watch. Not a huge TV. I asked.
That's what I'm saying. You know what I
like? Do you know what Youtube is doing?
That's awesome. Now anytime
you punch in like, um,
like if you punch in moon hoax,
like if you want to watch a conspiracy
theory video on the moon hoax,
they're going to put a link right on,
right under it boomed.
It takes you to the Wikipedia of, uh, of
the Apollo landings. Like all the, oh,
that's cool. Yeah. Just,
they're basically debunking the conspiracy
theory video right there for ya.
I'm watching hot naked chicks on youtube.
Let's see if it happens.
What do you got? Okay.
It's just a photo shoot.
Fast forward a little bit. Yeah.
Dude, look at that. Did you see that?
What's that damn jacking off to you
dude? Right. Look at that. Hello. Whoa.
She's got to run now, but wait, I saw
Ted, you some big ass duties. Hold on.
Come on Bro. Look at that. Oh, the houses,
they can take their shirts off. Why
can't women, I guess they can, dude.
You won't see 'em you won't
see Genitalia in San Francisco.
Well, and then he says, just wait at time.
Do you know what the rule is in
San Francisco? What? Look at that.
You guys didn't know this.
No, Bro. Wait a minute.
You can see naked vaginas.
I kicked your Bush out of my face.
San Francisco.
You can walk around naked,
but you know what the rule is if
you're a man, can't touch me. What?
What's the what? Yeah. I can't get
hard dude with the breeze kid. Hey Bro.
Tough Schatz attention or something.
You can be naked.
Just don't have a hard on to. Why
is this, this is crazy. Eddie,
how'd you find out about this? I just
thought I just punched it into yourself.
Just go. Hmm. Let me see what
I would just check with you do.
I was just checking it cause he's,
he's a scientist Bro.
Bro. Research row. Now what am I
going to research? That is crazy,
crazy. No idea. How bout, how bout them?
The bunker videos on conspiracy.
Like if you put in,
put a punch in moon hoax right now.
A link at the bottom of it right under
the video. But if I titled the Mood,
but if I type in moon landing does
send me some hoax to no, no it doesn't.
It doesn't do that. No, no, no, no, no.
That would be good. Alistair Overeem.
Oh, you know he changed Kansas elevation
elevation in Denver, Colorado. Christian,
Alan Cody Donovan. And it looks good.
Like the way he looks physically there.
He looks good. He does look good.
A lot of heavy wrestling there.
It's so funny. It's even though he looks
great, like you look at him right now,
you go, damn, he looks great.
The problem with him is you always
judge him against what he looked like.
So he came when he fought Brock,
when he was ubering,
when he was the k one Grand Prix champion.
When the bus dude, when he was ubering,
he was a special thing. Like he was a
special thing. No one wanted to fight him.
No, can't beat that guy. Yes.
Came Pete that Uber Rain. Am I
going crazy right? Cain, Cain,
Pete,
him.
[inaudible] he never had might a lot of
hard nuts or am I thinking Brock Lesnar,
you seeing a Brock Lez guy beat the
shit out of him. Cain didn't fight Uber.
Him Ever? No, he did it. He beat he
beat Brock. Yeah. And thinking of Brian,
he smashed Bra. Did he ever
fight about a Hari? Yes. Yes.
He knocked Badr Hari out with a left Hook
and Buhari stopped him in the rematch
but high. Yes. But how he
stopped him? Yeah. Badr.
Hari stopped him in the rematch in the
first fight with butter. Hari. I told him,
I think the story was that bought
her heart was not training very much.
Has He retired? Bought her? No.
You could fall. Rigo Bro. Hoobin and
broke his arm. He's not trying to do,
I'm in May though. Right? Did he go to
jail? He fought one MMA fight, I believe.
Butter. Hardier management. Why do you
get it? You got to jail a couple times.
Fuck you. Fuck the shit out of people
putting them hands on motherfucker.
Badr Hari. So scary. I
mean, dude. He's like, Nah,
fuck with that guy. He's a
knockout. Hemper yeah, but,
but it pays off in fighting and he's,
he's got some amazing fights on his
highlight reel, dude. How about,
how about your first fight in the UFC?
This Russian dude, I'll see the champion,
this Russian organization and they're
like, hey, you got to call the UFC cool.
Who am I fighting? Alistair Overeem,
like, can I ask you a question?
I get those warm up.
How many times has he been knocked out?
153 are shitting really bad every time.
I see it isn't,
it isn't cause he wins and you know,
it's the, it's the, you know, it's,
he's at heavyweight. That
guy used to fight. Well,
we just accept the fact Polish guy.
Right? Is that Christoph says Zinsky no,
it's John Shara. Okay. Sorry. Oh,
he looks like it's Jeff Munson.
Ciesynski had a, he had fucking
tattoos everywhere. Still
does. It's white as shit.
He's a white guy. He's Russian Bro. Man.
He's white. White. That blends with snow.
So like when you're looking at over him,
even though he does look great,
you compare his looking great to
what he looked like when he was Uber.
Did he looks fucking good though. Oh
yeah. A version of Uber Him. Yeah.
But if he like,
well he used to be a fucking nine 11 gts,
three Rs and now he's just a regular
nine 11 there's a good way of putting it
now. He's like a career
Targa how old is he now?
He's getting up there. He's 38
yeah, he's getting up there guys.
And he's been fighting forever. Most
skilled heavyweight. Striking. Oh Sue,
still fuck. He's highly skilled.
Highly skilled. K One champ.
That's what I'm a cowboys. Toronto. He
said that he's like sparring with him.
Is it such a joy because he's
so technical. So good. Oh Shit.
Watch out for that. I mean he's, he's won
more than share. He's lost a bunch too,
but he's one of the best trackers
to ever fight. Never man.
I'm going with Papa Lovett. You on
this fight. I'm taking my over him.
He's going to hurt. Yeah, he's gonna.
I, I'm impressed with the strength.
You think he's hurt?
No.
I mean he got hit but when
he's hurt you know it,
it doesn't take much with the
government cause he's been hit so many,
put out so many times he thought, oh
he's full. Still pretty good though.
You got clipped there.
He just,
he just doesn't take shots as well
as he did when he was ubering to,
because of the size of his neck,
his neck and his traps.
He used to have like these built in shock
absorbers all run his head. Yeah. Isn't,
isn't glass Justin Drum reel though,
where your body shuts down.
It's your brain from so much trauma.
So as soon as nasty trauma that Nope,
we're not doing this anymore.
It's really not. I
asked, he needed a bone.
It's your brain at your child's just
got some fucking knees man. Yeah.
So definitely the best need.
Shadow Dude, skull shore.
That guy that got knocked out. He had,
I dunno, I dunno how he got knocked out,
but it was on the news that uh,
um,
he had a severe concussion maybe,
you know,
maybe it was in a coma and he wakes up
and he's super smart. He knows all this.
Like he's a genius man.
My name Brendan,
just Brian counts to struck by
lightening the Oliver Sacks.
This guy got us a thing, not a
John Travolta movie. The Guy,
the guy who got struck by lightning,
who became obsessed with piano and
became a concert pianist, but down,
it's a true story, sac study. But
there's also someone who got fucked,
either lightning or a w
had a horrible concussion.
Woke up just fluent in Chinese
so she, okay. So it happens.
Shit happens when it's one of those
things where you hear about it and you go,
wait a minute, wait a minute. Never
met him though. I mean read this story.
Those stories are bullshit.
I think there's some people
that definitely gets struck
by lightning and then
all of sudden they're good at math.
What if it's true? What if we,
what if we find out? It turns out
that the more you get knocked out,
the smarter you get. That's what
happened to me. How, how cool training,
how cool would kickboxing training
people lose?
Just gave it be stupid. But then you'd
get to knock people over on a daily basis,
ground and pound and thinking that
he's been working with Curtis Blade,
so I'm assuming he's been
working on this a shitload.
What I think is really cool is when
a mathematician works on a crazy math
problem his whole life,
it has no bears,
no relevance to the physical
world in a hundred years later,
years later they're using it to put a
rover on Mars or something like it has
relevance a hundred years later
over Raymont top nasty ground.
And pound man just hit me. I'm a
little high. Do you remember when, uh,
do you remember when? Of course we don't.
Did you see that fucking missionary?
The Christian missionary
went to that island in India.
It's still a saint and
island and he's like, no,
I'm going to give the word of Jesus.
And Jesus loves you too.
And he and they're like Ha.
And then killed him instant.
I think he got shot through the glass.
I think Ireland. Is that what you said?
Something like Sentinel Island,
north central island. They,
they left Africa 60,000 years ago and
they would live it on this island.
And what's interesting is to say,
Guy, I tweeted it on my page,
there's a guy over and finish him off
cause fights or shout out till it's over.
Powerful.
I always root for over him now to me the
holds on that mother fucker still doing
it, man. 38 doing it, doing it right there
too. One more win. And he's a title shot.
He's always that guy. Dot
over it. Well he's definitely
in the hunt for it. I mean,
look,
when he fought steep a member
when he hurts deep bay.
Yeah.
It's just as possible that he could have
stopped [inaudible] number and they're
like, Joe, let's bring that up,
you know? Well, maybe not there.
Well that was when I decided not to
interview people that have been killed or
just like, it's not fair. They don't,
they have a false memory like to get
just got knocked out by steep Amy.
Oh chick dude. I wouldn't mind seeing
him first. France, Francis again.
You crazy son.
I don't want to see that again.
I don't want to see anybody
get hit like that again.
If I go through the rest of my days,
what are we talking about?
Satan guy or the island. Oh, sentinel.
So here's what's crazy.
They used to be,
they used to be sort of uncontacted but
they got contacted in the 18 hundreds by
this guy.
Now this is a guy a on Twitter posted
this amazing review with all this stuff
is, is his name is respectable law on, um,
on,
on Twitter.
So he posted this really long detailed
history of what happened to these people.
And a guy name Maurice Vital,
V v Dow Portman.
And this guy,
uh,
apparently stayed on the island for a
long time and people got sick because of
these people being there. They don't
have any diaries. They have no will,
they have no immunity to,
but he measured their Dick Sizes and
you measured, their boss has his,
he made them pose and all these weird
ways like it's really freaky shit,
but really, really
interesting. You're like, okay,
he's measuring the children and stuff
like treated them like in Weirdo him offs
and stuff, but talked about them
like in really weird sexual terms.
And this guy was such a bad
experience for those people that uh,
they're the devil and it was
a bike a hundred years ago.
So when people go back now,
they immediately kill him.
So because of this one Dick Wad that
landed there a hundred years ago,
they think of white people as evil.
So these two fishermen fell asleep and
I want to say it was like 2006 they fell
asleep and their boat drifted
onto the island. They woke up,
they just fucking Hatcher dumb.
And to them and killed him on the beach.
They live, they don't fuck around
anymore. Think about this one asshole.
If you think about it,
it's really smart in a fuck
that way because if they get in,
come into contact one of us,
the entire,
their entire population could be wiped
out because they don't have immunity.
They're saintliness, right? No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. Right. You sure?
No, no, no, no, no, no. David
confirmed them. I heard this
from good morning. I'm no, no,
no, no, not good morning America
set the North Sentinel island dude.
I'm pretty sure the last full
saintliness island. Here's the deal,
Brendan St on even Satan, Satan
is a western concept. He just,
they have no idea.
They just hate white people.
Oh well is there what they don't
like foreign people who's gene?
I Dunno by an actor it has name of,
they just didn't say white people cause
that one dude came to fuck everything up
and then you see a white person kill him
data. We don't even know their language.
So to say they're satanists is crazy.
It's like saying that you understand
what they're saying. That's the room.
How big is, how big is that island? A
translator was in Manhattan. Really?
Now they don't have a translator. Eddie,
they don't even any contact at all.
The outside world. It's illegal. Oh,
that guy got killed and he paid
illegally to go with it. What are they?
To leave her and go to?
The fishermen got arrested.
So there was a cargo ship that ran
a ground there many years ago here.
There was in 1981. Uh, and uh,
the crew radioed for assistance and then
they got 50 men with bows and arrows
were showing up to, to try to get to the
boat and they helicoptered them away.
The boat is still there.
So this is a crazy ass placement.
Sounds like an awesome movie. So I know.
And then from that, from that boat,
they started getting metal tools because
they didn't have metal before that.
So until the 19, was it 1980 81? Yeah.
So now these,
these people took pieces of metal and,
and cold forged them
into weapons and shit,
like pounded them down with rocks and,
and created knives and stuff.
But these people,
they're essentially living the same
way people lived 60,000 years ago.
They've been on this isolated
island ever since then.
It's of maybe we should just fly over
and drop a ton of iPhones everywhere.
There's the problem. They don't know
how many of them, there aren't any more,
but they know their populations
are declining. So at once,
at one point in time there was a 150 plus
documented and now they think it might
be as low as 39 cause disease and stuff.
They don't have any,
just fucking probably board of
Methodist. Stop fucking, you know,
trying to get fish.
You don't have time to raise the kid.
Which one are you talking
about? This? Emily's, yeah,
there their population that
he left drastically dropping.
There's no a generic,
there's no genetic diversity there.
It's like, I'm sure, yeah, 3,900 folks,
39 folks is a small number. If
they're really down to that few. And,
uh, you know, they're real,
real aggressive when anybody
comes anywhere near them.
But the thing is, now that
we all know about it be, I'm
a part of the problem too,
right? We were all talking about
this. Now that we all know about it,
more people are going to think
about going there. Thank you.
A hundred bucks a year of that. And I
say, fuck leaving the United States,
hundred percent where is that place?
It's somewhere off of India.
They have bingo. They have been
gone. So it doesn't seem that remote.
If it's an Ebay, it's pretty far. It's
far away. It's hard to it literally.
It's illegal. It's like in the middle
of the ocean wrinkle. So homeboy,
he was doing God's work. It was
like, no, I can do it. And even Ryan,
his journals like, man, I hope I don't die
if I do. My parents don't be mad at me.
I'm headed this island.
Yeah. What the fuck were you
thinking, man? Well, he's crazy.
He's trying to convert people. He thinks
people need Jesus the same language.
They don't have any idea what he's saying.
He's from oral Roberts heart graduated
from Oral Roberts University, right? Yeah.
See there. That's where
it is. C as well. Shit.
Way Out there and a half stars out of fun.
So let's go in there.
If I go with it,
and that's given it all this
reviews, you get defeated. Go ahead.
Then you'll go ahead and then there's a
suite four seasons. They have great food.
It's called human that's going
to eat you bitch. Oh, so they,
they killed the guy and then they
buried him right on the beach. Man.
They just dragged his body out to the
beach and the Sherman Indian government
said, we're not going to do anything
about it. And it was a shit there.
That's all they know. Well,
yeah. I mean, first of all, they,
their law is you can't visit their island.
That's their law.
So he was violating their law,
him showing up with a this book.
I would imagine they'd, they
have laws against people
visiting, especially whites.
Yeah, man. That,
that story that they tell about that
one English guy that went there,
that was a piece of shit
fucked up for everybody.
I hope that guy respectable
law on Twitter, uh,
understands how much I appreciate
that. So that was cool. Yeah.
So they're all songs.
The just I need to read more navy seals.
Oh yeah.
Take them all out. Automatic. It would
be a cool video.
You never know.
They might have some crazy booby traps.
They might have some Vietcong Shit for
beautiful vacation toe,
but it's Starbucks.
Look at the person with the locals.
When here was my girlfriend for a holiday,
I loved it. She wasn't impressed. Very
poor choice for a romantic getaway.
Great choice for anyone
looking to rough it up a bit.
So silly. People are so funny. Well,
that island though is um, there's
gotta be people going, fuck no.
Under the coming century.
Dan Bilzerian is going to be there
next month with a bikini on the house.
It's going to just send a boatload of vape
pens. It was that I was taking a piss.
India, India, India.
They came from Africa
though 60,000 years ago.
It's like draws closer to Thailand.
Pretty amazing. Just kind
of, they know that how, how,
how would they figure that out if you're
not allowed to go on the island that
they'd been around 60,000 years ago? It's
a good question. I don't know. Well, it's,
I can pop on a Guinea. Those tribes have
been isolated for, for 40,000 years. Yeah,
still. Yeah. Not Anymore. But I mean,
when Jared diamond went and studied them,
they'd been isolated for that long.
They practice weird things too,
like widow strangling and
all kinds of screening widow,
stranger and that one
tribe where you were,
the young boys suck the Cox of the older
men and take it in their ass as well to
become men.
So they in the sperm,
it's not just some weird started that.
If you don't have somebody that can,
can compete with those ideas,
then that gets passed down as religion.
I've got to Piss.
So tell me who wins what. I Never
Seen Him take a pee break. No. Yeah,
the first, first time. Love. There
you go. That's right. We can pause.
Go on with your little lilac.
Sure.
Frances and got on boys.
I'm excited about this fight,
which Jack does always. Yeah,
it's a big fight for a minute.
Cause remember he beat him last time,
but he's coming off that steep a ass
whooping and then had the horrible fight
against Derek Lewis, which is like the
worst heavyweight fight of all time.
No one won that fight.
Obviously Derek won that fight because
the judges and then Derek goes on to
fight for it. Since then, this is his
first fight since Derek Lewis. Oh Shit.
I don't like it because obviously he
struggles with wrassling so like go,
here's Curtis plays the best wrestler
in the top five. I just don't like it.
I would show the game someone
else who matched up better,
no matter if he wins or loses. I just
don't think it was a great idea. Um,
is he from Chad? Where's he
from? Ghana. Chad the Congo.
Congo. You shoot man. I
thought he was from more west.
I think it's the Congo. Jamie. Yeah.
Yeah.
Curtis placements in Ghana. That's
a French name. So it makes sense.
He's from the Congo. I'm pretty sure it
was tango policies sees Ghana, Cameroon.
Is that where he's from?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well Cameron's one of the last places
where there's like sort of continuous
habitat for different animals. Oh,
he's coming out to mortal Kombat but up
woo,
great tune.
Now they're fighting at three
30 in the morning our time.
So it's a bit of a time Chad Shit time.
Curtis blades just always fights on
foreign land. When did they get there?
How many days do you need to adjust that?
They had thanksgiving over there,
so I'm assuming they get,
well I imagine he gets,
he flies in on Tuesday like any
other fight week. Right. Do what?
I would want to come early. It's hard
to get used to sleeping over there.
I can't imagine. Yeah, it,
I was in Thailand in here.
Can't you just try to take naps and you
can but the sunset and all that fucks
you up.
The best way I say it,
they say it's just fast for
like 16 hours and then eat.
I like when you get there in the morning,
eat,
have breakfast and just get on the same,
your body gets used to the eating cycle.
Fastings were they important? Apparently
for. Okay. That's what you did over there.
I be,
I tried.
I tried to work now and you're still
tired but you still thinking of moving to
China? I am going to go to Beijing
and living in an apartment.
Are you going to be a political dissident?
I'm mean,
I'm marching and [inaudible] Australia
as a time change fucked me up.
I was exhausted and he came back up.
I go in there, I was fine coming back.
I was so fucked up in that weird that
it's going back somehow or another dose
two or uh,
you know what I need to try taking
Melatonin like one I land like when I,
when I need to go to bed that night.
Yeah, I don't think so. I try to help,
you know what helps me? CBD Oil. Yeah. It
helps me relax. I take it in the morning,
but especially at night, at
night, it helps me without,
without the thing that seems to be about
reset my system better than anything is
a serious fucking workout look like,
show up somewhere and do a serious
workout, like to push a cardio,
lift some weights,
like really get tired and that
seems to set me, set me up,
did that and I've kind of
stopped because I was so funny.
I said that I started when I was
in Afghanistan while we worked out,
me and Deb David, I've worked out
like a motherfucker and I did.
It helped me a lot. I felt way
better. It puts your cycle, Babs,
you're afraid the whole time. Usually on
the road, wherever I land I worked out.
Yeah. When I land I'll work out
and I feel better. That's the moon.
But there's a new scientific study range.
Crisper, like everything's better. Yeah.
This, this scientific study. I'll
find it at the end of my phone. Yeah,
please get where we're at.
We're fasting for 16 hours is the most
important thing you can do and then reset
time changed.
I usually sending your clock with
however they were eating there because
[inaudible] 91 yeah, I've heard that
you should not eat on planes too.
I've heard that you're better off just
not eating on planes on the ground plane.
When you get,
when you land like your,
your body will be better off falling
into this new time zone when you land.
If you just don't need on that you
don't even know I'm playing to ever.
I meditate on his position,
dude.
When they come by with that card and they
get that snack tray. Yeah. Nice cheeses,
fruits and shit. Pringles. Sometimes
I just want a banana. I me too.
Sometimes I just want to Swedish
fish. Ah, I talked to Pat. His fish.
Yeah. And Pringles smoke macro. The
sweetest fish and the little crack. No,
no sweets Fisher though. That candies
you don't, you do sometimes if I,
if I'm feeling Frisky,
damn.
I feel like I've earned it if I'm coming
back from a long fricking couple of
nights.
So the thing,
I never feel like I earned those
every time he thought it was.
I feel like a bad boy
and I don't feel great.
After I flew first class to London and
they got food and I was eating cheeses
and wines to get hammered.
No,
but I just kept drinking and
eating and I just felt like,
fuck you shit on the plane.
Um, no, I don't think so.
You felt terrible when you landed.
I was just one big sodium Bob. Yes.
I'll have more chase. Do you have a
wheel back there? Sure. And I'll leave.
I know another ice cream Sundae. I just
went a little crazy and wine. Yeah,
that's what that fucks me. I find
the do good writing on planes though.
You get some good ideas out because
it's just you alone staring at this,
you're not moving right. You're,
you're confined to this little seat.
You're not going anywhere. Sometimes good
ideas come when you just sit like that.
It's so easy to just fuck off. When
you're at home. I know you're writing,
you just,
it's so easy to just get,
let me see what's in the fridge and me
go grab a cup of coffee. I set a timer,
23 minutes. I don't know why but
23 minutes and then I can't move.
Kayla's good man. I
think I just, you know,
I just forced myself to do it.
The thing is,
what's weird about it is for whatever
reason I resist doing it at first like,
ah, but then once I get into it and
I catch a groove, I love it. Yeah.
It's like getting into a cold bath.
Like at first your skin's like mark
and then you're like, Oh yeah, I uh,
I think everything is that way.
I think inspiring yourself to kind of
get started and then kind of figure out a
way to keep it even working out though.
I did did my class this
morning in that box,
morning cardio class and when we start
I'm like, God, it, why did I come?
And then halfway through I'm like, this
is great. Yeah. Well you know what man,
I fucked myself up. But that a sober
October fitness challenge thing,
that's a bad idea and this is what
fucks you up. Like afterwards,
you look regular working out.
It seems boring because
everything was this cycle hours,
five hours a day.
We're competing against each other.
You'd get anxiety like check the APP,
see where everybody's scores. That shit.
Fuck. You know you need, you can do that.
You still beating against Bert
Kreischer, Arusha, fear and Tom Segura.
So let's take it easy. No, I'm
not saying I'm still, you still.
You know what I mean? Like
my competition, those guys,
he's going to coast. The
last guy. Competitiveness.
I'm telling you, man brushed him. Joe.
Joe was like Glass Cham Haynes in that
motherfuckers would have no chance.
Kim Haines and me and that bitch.
We should do a real fitness dude.
I'm telling you, even if
you're doing it, the thing is,
it's about how much time you spend.
It's about how hard you worked down.
See, it's like how much time are you
spending at 80% of your Max heart rate?
That's really what it's been. That's
watch how fast and Gannaway is Jesus. Oh,
he's terrifying. We should probably wash.
He's laying on his feet too, right? Yeah.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God,
he just so powerful. Oh
my God. Ooh. Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, that's it.
That's it. That's it. Dan.
He's back. Oh my God.
Starched him. Wow. You can't,
that was crazy. Tad of an early
stoppage, but I don't know.
It looked like it was almost an early
stopped working his way back up. No,
I don't think it was around.
I stop thinking.
I was going to say it looked like it was
almost early stoppage and then they let
it go on and then it was a
decent stop. Yeah, I agree.
Because that's how you save a fighter.
It seem like that's,
how are you getting that? They were
going to stop it. Yeah. He got,
he got concussed right away.
He got percent three chances Curtis
place 26 years old. Give him,
he's got a lot of fight left in them,
so just that's a good stop. It's fine.
He's just got caught. Literally
just got cut. Good stops. The only,
I think it was the only way
he's gonna lose this fight.
It's getting cut. Yup. God.
That's what happened.
Got to look fast. Listen.
That's the levels of standup between them.
You know what I mean?
Curtis blades is a good stand up fighter,
but a really good wrestler.
His wrestling stats, so like the, some of
the best in the heavyweight division. He,
Beth, as far as a successful taping on
the back of the head with that hammer.
God, boom. See like right there. It
looked like the ref was about to stop it.
Boom. Wow. So much power runs over
there and look, he touches them.
He touched him.
You're not supposed to touch him.
He prayed to his friend and knew
my name. Yeah. I don't know man.
I thought he was going to stop, boom. And
that then he decided to it. That's it.
That's it. That's it. That's a
dangerous job, man. Supersede that.
A clip from the Moitai, one of the, uh,
Moy Tai websites has it up there of
this referee is stepping in to stop this
fight and then it's a head
case. I saw it. He gets it.
Takes a shin right to the dome,
gets knocked the fuck out while he stayed
conscious, but he went down. Let me see.
It's moving, but he get head
kicked. That's a dangerous man.
And the first thing you imagine
me and Curtis page right now,
you took the plane for 20 hours to fly
over to get knocked down. 45 seconds.
They'll worst. Yeah. The longest
possibility within Ghana.
God damn good frigging in
Ghana and get back on track.
I wasn't crazy about the fight for him.
Yeah. What did he say about that fight?
Officially? Which one? Where
he didn't throw any punches.
He said the carried the fear of
his last fight is confidence.
And then Dennis was hurt. So
you get a shit show, you know,
it's neither one of those fault
Dick was hurt with his back.
Francis had no confidence.
It was crazy.
I mean it was the squeakiest of squeaky
margins for Derek to win because nothing
really happened in the fight they had.
No one really won.
It was just while we were talking about
that fight. We were like, Ho Lee Shit.
This is going to be bombs away.
That's why I think yes,
people say it's the worst heavyweight
fight cause you just thought it was going
be fucking fireworks. I think I
might've even said in the commentary,
there's not a doubt in my mind
that this is going to be crazy.
But who wouldn't think that? That's fair
to think with their two fighting styles.
I didn't know thought it was going
to be chaos. I thought awesome.
Derek is going to be throwing
haymakers trying to find his chin.
I'd like to see him go at it again.
That I would love to see that as Floyd
really fighting that one kickbox yes.
Yeah. You Know David agreed to.
It's real but it's going to be a,
an exhibition boxing match.
Fake kind. It's a boxing match.
They're probably going to wear big
gloves. No kicks, no checks. No.
Unless it's too smart for that.
Unless the fucking,
the Japanese just say Oh okay. So we
agree. Kick it too. Unless, unless,
unless the accuser goes
up to that kid and go,
hey here fucking head kick him Kale.
We're going to give you a $2 million
in the middle of the first round.
Kind of cool to see. But they'll rush
you through some contract negotiations.
Okay. He would go. It was
weird cause Floyd was like,
that was all bullshit and we agreed to
any of this. Then a week later he's like,
actually we're going to do it.
Listen the Japanese or they
do a different kind of business.
They're very clever over there.
You know the UFC got kind of the got
kind of like when you look at the,
the sale of pride, you know, like
what happened with all that? They,
they did a smart thing,
a really smart thing.
One thing that came over and they
pretended they were going to have pride
fighters fight in the UFC and
UFC fighters. Frightened pride.
Remember that in the early days,
like the EOC that shuffle the child,
the Dell over there and they were going
to bring fighters over to America.
He never did. Yeah. No, they never did.
I had to wait until they bought it.
And then when they bought it, they
basically just bought a DVD library. Yep.
And they spend like $60 million for pride.
And when they got it,
they couldn't even run it.
So then they had these people that were
running the office and these people were
in the office. They just went off and
made dream. They made their own shit.
And so they were like sold basically a
logo and a brand and these contracts,
the contracts weren't even any good.
Like they didn't like a lot of the
fighters were not bound to them, you know,
like fate or like they didn't
have fade or they did this,
they didn't have a lot of things and
they owed a lot of guys money and they
thought they were going to
operate in Japan. Like what?
We're going to run pride too is what like
right, that shit. No chance male way.
But what they did with those smart is the,
the first thing pride did was they pumped
up their own value by bringing their
fighters over here and pretending they're
fighters going to fight you. Chocolate.
Dell, remember they had that crazy
stare down way back in the day, but,
but then they never did. We, everybody's
always talking about nothing happened.
But after that, what they did not
want pride mentioned on the air. No,
they hate him.
Dre want them their name men.
How is Bella towards to
say they fought in Japan.
The USC also honey dicked the WME, when
they sold their thing, like, look dude,
we got Rhonda, we got
Brock, we got Connor,
we're doing all this big shit man.
And then they sold it for $4 billion
and like I run is going to retire,
so we can't do nothing about that Bronx
over in WWII. So we'll figure that out.
Well the Rhonda and then college for
two years of purchase, they, that was,
they had already purchased it.
That was the last Ronda fight.
The Comeback Fire they
had already purchased.
That's also probably why it was marketed
the way it was marketed. Correct.
Because all eggs in a,
that was one of the rare times where
I publicly was like, this is not,
here's aren't doing the right thing
because the Amanda Nunez, the champion,
she's a world champion. She stopped
me. Should teach you, strangled her.
Like you gotta give her respect.
She still not as respect as she should be,
but that was, that was a crazy one.
That was the worst one I've ever shows.
All Rhonda,
nothing of a manager and a couple seconds
just like Amanda doing something real
quick and that's it.
Like there should like hitting the bag,
but the rest was first ever women's MMA
champion that that's a lesbian first
ever. UFC with her girlfriend. The corner.
Yeah. Who's also a courtesy champion.
So first ever gay UFC champion.
Right.
And no one talks we know of that we
know of. Right. I think that's it.
I think it was point we haven't that
women's and made that long for champions.
Well, you're saying you're
saying guy or Gal? Girl. I'm
just trying to be funny.
I started thinking about what gave
champion. I was like, who could be gay?
But Amanda Versus Cyborgists
Hoop or interesting.
Super interesting to me because
uh, you know, sideboards,
she's way bigger.
She's bigger.
How about Amanda or Cal Pennington and
both their girlfriends fight in the UFC
two and then in their corners.
Crazy. That's insane. Insane
in a bad way, but cool.
Yeah. I mean we've come a long
ways. Yeah. It's different.
It's fascinating to watch
her bag. Yeah. JDS fighting.
Um, they both been out a fucking
grip. Keynes coming back here.
That, is that real? Yeah, Dude.
I'm 19 but when did they have a date?
No,
just announce he's back
in DC. Posted. Hey,
he said the belts waiting for
the champ. Whoa, he's back.
So what do you guys think
of Amanda Against Cyborg?
I think Amanda's got to move. I
think a only she have a chance. Sure.
She's got a chance. She's a beast,
but, oh shit. That's a great fight.
Tied to a Vasa Janie. That's right.
The mother fucking fight. You right.
Favorite could probably be Cyborg.
I don't, there's no, there's no,
there's no girls. But she's
like Joana, man, it's not
happening. She's got a chance.
Amanda Nunez is probably my favorite
female fighter too. I really wouldn't.
She walked around that.
What do you think, Amanda?
She's probably in the one
sixties if I had to guess.
And what do you think cyborg walks
around that we went through this right?
She said she's down there. You know,
she got mad. She was bigger. She, she's
such an animal. She is so much bigger.
That's going to be a crazy fight,
man.
That's on the same card as a
Gus van Jones too too. Yeah.
Yeah. Gus, it's been a hot minute.
She can't wait for that fight.
Yeah, I know. Right. I think the key to,
to anybody that's going to be able to
beat Cyborg is you're going to have to
catch her coming in and having her cock.
No girl, no girls beating the
sidebar. No girls being cyborg.
There's not a girl on this
planet that can beat side,
but what about that one dude?
The turned into a check.
She would get fucking dealt with. What? Or
she lost her last fight?
Fallon. Fox. Ashley. Evan Smith.
Who's in the UFC beat her
dad. Yeah. Nice sideboard.
Beat both of them up at the
same time. Now. I mean she does.
She's such an animal man.
You seen her spar with like dude and
then that Olympian, she was a shield.
Who's a world champion. Yeah,
like dude, she does not fuck up.
She doesn't fuck around and she's waiting.
This is our last fight on a contract
to, well, you know what man?
I mean I could easily see someone like
one fc grabbing her as well. Look,
they're grabbing a lot of people now.
It's really interesting to me
grabbing though they have to sign.
You should tape but that's business.
Well we got Eddie Alvarez.
He just went over there. Three guy,
Demetrius mighty mouse Johnson.
We just went over there and uh,
they're looking to expand the roster and
I think they're looking to also break
into the western market place.
You know they have that APP.
You can get the APP and watch
the fights on your phone. Yeah,
I've only seen highlights.
I've only seen highlight to one FC.
I've never seen him watch it for free.
How, how's Belterra today in comparison?
Yes. Bella towards not doing as well
as the UFC, but they're doing well.
They're doing well on the paramount
network. They get pretty good ratings to,
but they also with Rory
Mcdonald Gig Army Saucy,
then with the heavyweight with bait or
fade or like the heavyweight tournament
was sick. Yeah, they're doing well.
The think about Oscar de la Hoya
promoting them and like complete shit.
Show this one. Not this one.
Do you see the last one I did.
Did you see him at a press
conference? I want to see chuck
and Tito. No, no, no, not,
it's not a shit show cause it's chuck
and Tito. Do you see Oscar de la Hoya?
He's like, you got, you got
chocolate [inaudible] name wrong.
Then he goes and then you have these other
guys. How did he go? Check window? Uh,
I forget it. I lie down. Lie Down.
Everyone used to say chuck lie down.
I used to say at first,
that's what you say in a shyness.
He didn't know any of the
fighters and he was the first one.
You give them a little bit of that,
but what else did he say?
He goes and then we'll, you know, we have
other fights too. These guys behind me,
I don't know their names, but you know,
I'm not gonna remember their shit. No Way.
Yeah, there's just dead
silence. He's like, you know,
and when you think of him in May, when
you think of fighters at all, you know,
you just think of these two.
There's no one else that is the dumbest
way to promote a fight. It was so nice.
Oscar's had, you know how many
professional fights? A lot,
and he snorts all the cocaine. Does he do
all of it? Watch this press conference.
He's all, and uh, he was like, whoa.
Where it's freezing it does that mean,
is that a fact? No, he's admitted.
He came on there was the dad abuse prom
and pretty, it's like devil's Dandruff.
I don't think his love and his Dandruff,
I don't think his love his MMA is
love his boxing. It's just, you know,
he's doing this one,
you know,
I hope it does well because Tito and chuck
will get benefit the most from it for
the money. So I want people to buy it
because that reason hammer stone the game.
No, no. He was my
manager. What? Holy Shit.
Oh yeah, they had long talks. Great
Dude's smart dude. What happened?
Why did he get out of MMA? Because
it's bullshit, you know? He was like,
why did I like money?
Fuck this sport.
How else is he making money? A dude, he's
one of the first investors in Facebook,
Twitter, Twitter. So He's filthy
rich. Yeah. Oh Shit. Okay.
He goes, and I remember
he said, he goes, well,
there's a difference between you and
bankrupt and be an MC hammer. Bankrupt.
He was, I wasn't like poor. So
you got still balling? Yeah.
Yeah. He started like 12.
Nine was, he's smart dude,
man. I'm sure. Interesting.
Um, what were we just talking
about before the four MC Hammer.
Amanda Nunez and Chris Herman. No,
no, that was way long. Devil island.
If you're white, you can't go
to the island anymore. That
will completely lost Yammer.
Uh,
we were talking about promoting,
oh, what fc. Oh, what I've seen,
look, I hope they all do good. We just,
you definitely need like more competition,
more fun. There's more fighters in
there are fights. Right. And uh,
the hard thing though is that
the UFC is like cue tips, right?
It's like when you think
you don't want cotton swabs,
give me some fucking cute tips.
They they've got the market. You're,
there's tissue Kleenex. Yeah, for
now. For now, but there's always,
I don't know if there's such a, it's
such a part of the cultural landscape.
Like some people go, oh
do you do you UFC? Yeah.
How fucking dare you hoped that they
would get to the point. I would hope,
this is my goal.
My hope is that a lot of organizations
are like a lot of these boxing
organizations will you look at like
world champions like Deontay wilder was
about to fight Tyson fury.
You could have guys that have different
promoters and they worked together some
sort of a deal and then they
put together the fights.
That's better for the fighters if the
fights get in the fighters who both
organizations get it's popular, right.
As you know, it's like Manny Pacquiao,
fighting Floyd Mayweather.
They had to have these promoters figure
out how to put that fight together.
Sport better for everyone because we've
been asking is whooping ass over one fc
what you love if he just fought the
champion that you have short Bella tours
champion like gay army
saucy fight Woodley.
Right now we're fighting fighting
Whitaker. I'd love to see that.
They're going to be very happy
that they signed Ben Aspirin.
It's going to be fun.
He's smart.
He talks a lot of shit and it took
forever to get him over here and a lot of
people are in deep shit.
They're in deep shit.
He's going to grab a
hold of them and wrestle.
Fuck them to the ground
and punch their face.
Isn't that going to be much they going
to be able to do to a lot of people are
going to be real sharp man.
Like you look at the well he
goes anywhere the chin from that.
The interviews are scrum
for him. Yeah. Look man,
people who've seen the interviews online,
uh,
they seem the podcast that I did with
them, they've seen all of his fights.
You know, if you watch highlight
reels, you could see all of his fine.
When I Jack Him off every show we get
every show and then the u s are in one FC.
They allowed him to needed
the head on the ground too.
He gets site control now the fuck out
of your head. I'll see. Can't damn man.
It's a nightmare. You can also get north,
south, north, south knees to the head.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Fuck
somebody up is fs one? Yeah.
Oh fuck. Don't say fs. One, one FC. Oh,
when I say, I mean I know what you meant.
Fox sports one hasn't Channel One FC.
I meant but to be able to do that,
to be able to land knees to the
head on the ground like that,
those giant advantage for a restaurant,
giant advantage and to take it away from
them that you like limit like what is
really good about being on top.
It's really good about being on top
is you could smash them anywhere.
It's kind of weird. Those knees. Did
you hear the rumor about Cowboy Connor?
I did. Yeah. It could be sick. Fuck yeah.
I think hope. Can we get that fight?
I think that's a possibility.
I think that that's a moneymaking fight
and then you may sense for both the guys,
Connor Connor wants to Coby
rematch, but it's like, dude,
let's get one and then go back that way.
But you got to win. That would be really,
I'm not saying cowboys and easy fight,
but it's a better match up then could be
were Tony and then Tony could be fight.
It's going to be interesting to
see what kind of shit talking.
Cause Cowboy did not have a good time
with the shit. Talking of Nate Diaz,
he got in his hat or mosfet out.
He doesn't like that shit.
Talk doesn't like that Shit. Conor
goes, you guys did that watch.
Then he's going to wrap it up
to 11 until I think cowboy,
if he grabs a of the Connor
and takes him to the ground.
Condoms in a world of shit too.
Cause cowboys a hell of a wrestler and
a Halloween. He's a hell of a striker.
To me it's a different, it's a
different words. Not An easy fight.
It's gonna be called on the,
as far as the, the odds, I'm,
I'm assuming Conard barely be a
favorite if 91 55 one 55 Connors,
the the speed that he has,
the one shot Kao power.
Like Connor can do some
shit to motherfuckers and
when you see him fight Eddie
Alvarez,
that's when you really realize it.
Like Eddie Alvarez is tough as fuck and
Connor just put it on him. He can start,
he can fuck people up about
cowboy put it on navy too. He did.
But he didn't do it the same way. He
didn't meet his legs. He beat his legs up.
He didn't, he didn't see a
man shot. Connor Dis, Eddie.
Eddie might've been shots.
I think that also is a little misleading
cause I feel like a lot of that is
because Conor got into Eddie's head but,
and he's better than that.
Look at that shit and
he's been doing it long.
Conor McGregor is a two to one favorite.
That doesn't make any sense to me. Well,
it does make sense and
not as good a wrestler,
which makes sense because you're going
based off of how cowboy won his last
fight. Fallen some tough times. I left
out way more than anyone in this room. But
he's got the most winning record
in UFC history too, I believe.
So I'm also going by that. And he
did. He also has one more fun lately.
Well he looked fantastic
against Mike Perry, the amazing,
but Mike [inaudible] far cry from
congressman. Big Difference. But look,
I like the fire fighter.
I like to fight a lot.
And I do agree that if cowboy gets
a hold of anybody on the ground,
he's got crazy ground skills. Calcium,
crazy capital naked holding up a cowboy.
He's better off his bat.
Cause if Connor would it take him down,
he would be screwed. But cowboy and tops
not a technician on top. No, I disagree.
You think he's technician on top,
top caliber from his back cupboard
from his back. He's good everywhere.
Yes. Yes. But he'll fuck you up from
the top. He's got, he's got great.
Most of the submissions are from his back.
That's true because he throws a lot of
kicks and guys take them down and just
snapchat super special off
his back. He, but he's just,
he's very underrated as a grappler. Yeah.
And you saw many reversed Mike Perry.
Fucking amazing. Fucked his arm up.
How about my parents? He's not, he's,
he left Jackson's, he's like,
dude, I felt like it was, you know,
I didn't want to be part of came there
to train and all of a sudden I got put in
the middle of this drama. He left. He
left. Oh, was no longer there. Oh Wow.
You look great too. I thought
he looked good. He, you know,
obviously you had the hiccup of taking
cowboy down, but I thought Perry,
like pretty fucking good man.
Yeah, no, Perry did look very good.
He's been looking better and better,
but he just fucked up and took him down.
That fight was just, cowboy had his
number. Cowboy sparred with him.
Who knows how many times
they also Jackson's. Yeah.
And the, and the grappling,
apparently cowboy dominated him,
but I guess Perry said in when in their
training camp he was taking so many guys
down is almost like a natural
reaction from he goes, dude, I just,
part of the fight just took him down.
David thinking back,
cause that's what I was doing in
camp. Right. And then Winkeljohn goes,
that was not part of the plan.
We did not want to take cab way down.
So where's he gonna go now? I don't know.
I think he was att before, right? Yeah.
I don't know.
But for him it men,
he's getting so much better if he just
stays consistent, gets with a legit cam,
maybe get his ass up to Tristar were Aka,
I liked something about going to Montreal.
Sexy Malkai it's so cold, so
cold. The coldest I've ever been.
Plus in another country,
you know, you just,
it's so far you've got to also just
really super concentrate on what you're
doing because it's all you're doing.
Yeah. Well I liked beautiful city though.
That's like a strip club
and food.
I can live match allegedly. It's
amazing. I think that could happen.
Like you gotta you gotta beat,
I think got to be with
some one of the wizards.
There's many great wizards of MMA.
But to really maximize your potential,
you gotta be with someone who can
put it all together. You know,
and you could pick your favorite wizards,
but one of my favorite ones,
it's for sure it's for us. I think
he's like one of the best of not him.
Who has the best, one of
the best for sure. The best.
Rufus Matt Hume does not have very
many high level guys that have been,
I mean he did work with
Maurice though. All right. Yes,
he's in Ca AMC pankration. But he,
um, was a great fighter himself.
Just great knowledge of the game.
But what he,
just by proof of what he did with mighty
mouse and the way they talk to each
other in the corner,
and you realize like there's a system
they're operating under and they're like,
this is very high level, very
technical, very sophisticated.
They're staying one step
ahead of everything and they
know what they're doing.
For Demetrius. Demetrius, a
very cerebral, smart fighter.
So that doesn't necessarily mean
my peers can spiel plugin and work.
That's true to my pastor would do
great somewhere like uh, with uh,
Jason Parillo in San Diego.
That could be fucking a dope connection
for them or to find that right.
Coach alliance.
San Diego would be great too.
I feel like that'd be good for him down
there. There's always good spots, man.
But I think that uh, having a fresh look
is not the worst thing in the world,
but I think you can't have too many fresh.
Right.
So you gotta you gotta
put your roots somewhere,
otherwise you might learn his box.
Jaeger. Mark Henry. Yeah. Wow.
Phenomenal coach. One of the masterminds.
Yeah, he's one of the masters.
Barboza Edgar.
Eddie Alvarez
also owns a pizza place. Yeah. Is that,
yeah, that's my guy. That was his,
that was his pizza place. You
said it was really good. The best.
He actually tapped you actually send me
a text after you ate that pizza and you
go, I hate the best cause we are
talking about choline is PTA goes,
I ate the best pizza in the world bro.
I was like,
well that's a random tax question. I
don't give a shit. It's a different pizza.
I hate to be in that guy. But bagels
and pizza or different over there,
different water, they say,
right. It's different.
It's a different moisture
in the air on my diet.
I've been so good on my diet and getting,
you know, losing weight for my special,
but I've been good on my diet. What
are you doing? This special, different,
fascinating extra cardio. Say
How many hours a week? Uh, man,
I wake up at six and then I,
I quit eating at 6:00 PM at night,
so 66 and then I don't eat until
usually 10 or 11 the afternoons.
So wow. But anyways, um, anyway,
so, uh, I've been good on my diet,
but I go to New York next week and
artichoke pizza or King's pizza,
I think it's called King Street. I just
can't turn it down. Artichoke pizzas.
Your Shit. No, the company's called
our children. I fucking hate artichoke.
The white pizza. The white sauce.
Now that's not part of the shit.
You don't like that stuff? Fuck
No. I got to have red sauce man.
But our choke pizza New York.
My mouth's watering bro.
Just some places that
have good white pizza.
I didn't experience the whole pizza until
I had it at Nikki's in white plains or
she's pizzeria in white plains,
New York on the street right down
the street from executive billiards.
They had white pizza that will
knock your dick write in the dirt.
It had melted butter and garlic on it
and and ham and shit and you'd bite and
he'd be like holding. A lot of
Italians were in white white plains.
I mean he still to,
this is not my favorite is white castle.
Is White Castle still around?
I remember white castle or small burgers.
Burgers they make are Regan one
grow. They make it Vegan. White Cow.
Fuck yeah.
I'm pretty sure white castle for
only then make a Vegan Burger.
Now White Castle does,
which is like,
that's literally like buying a,
a vitamin from a poison factory.
That's a bad idea. Vitamins
too. Yeah. Yeah. Bad at night.
If you're a Vegan and like
you're buying Vegan Burgers,
soy from a company that rounders,
millions of animals a year.
Impossible Burger.
You feel better. Wow. How about Taco Bell?
Taco bell puts essentially sand
it while sodium bicarbonate,
Bro. Hey, no silicon by
carbon. I think I'll still go
there. There be filling. They're
not allowed to call it beef filling.
They have to call it Taco
filling because it's not beef.
That beef has silicone in it
to make it fuller and more. Um,
look it up. That shit.
That shit is delicious. Oh,
look up what's in Taco Bell. How
would you doubt that? Why do you,
how would you need for
this Taco Bell Taco?
That's a conspiracy theory.
A double decker Taco.
I don't give a fuck you bro.
There's no youtube blame.
It's not real. Is calen
true? Where'd you hear this?
Silica. Silica. Brian,
I believe you were
talking about Taco Bell.
It's not in their isolated oat product.
Some chili pepper, onion powder,
silicon dioxide, anti caking Asia.
Now look that up. So carbon dioxide,
sugar, please. Agent, how about that?
You guys love Taco? Okay, go guys.
What does it say? Anti kicking nature
to avoid clumping and supplements.
It's used to prevent the various powdered
ingredients from sticking together as
many food additives.
Consumers have often often have concerns
about silicon dioxide as an additive.
Is it safe?
Is it Sam to see that that they put in
there also frequently found in health
food nutritional supplements
as an additive cells.
Silicon dioxide primarily
functions as an anti kicking agent,
which prevents ingredients
from binding together,
but it doesn't say if it's cancerous
carcinogen.
Look at this proven carcinogen.
Well who set on Mcdonald's?
Answer their buns. So silk industrial
side is he proven carcinogen wives,
Mcdonald's opt to use this in buns,
potentially hurting human health.
Silicon is categorized
as a trace mineral then,
which means that it's needed in minimal
amounts to maintain health as his
requirement.
It's very small.
It's recommended daily allowance for
silicon has not been specified cause this
is not food.
However,
experts suggested a daily consumption and
the range of 2030 milligrams is needed
to stay healthy.
Who I wrote that cause that Mcdonald's,
Mcdonald's [inaudible] I guess
just a trace mineral maybe.
But maybe it is. Yeah,
it's important for sure.
But you know it has, you know, if
kid has like a slimy thing on it.
Here's the thing. If they can't really say
all this, if it's not true, if they do,
they get in deep shit.
So it might be real that
silicon is a trace mineral.
It's an important part of our own feed.
But it also,
you're putting dirt in your burgers.
Crow. It's also a food food grade.
So maybe it's different. So it's like
why is it in there though? Even if you,
you're saying it so Katie,
it doesn't kick up right?
You can't have a cookie.
Can have cake filler man.
36% beef.
Oh it's only 36% beef and talked to
other 64% is a wide range of fillers.
It cocoa powder over this 36% beef,
64% is made with fillers.
Don't we all know and preserve
of know that this is 100% beef
cow killed. You really think it was 64%
I don't think when I eat that, I'm like,
listen man,
this isn't
going to be good.
I'm going to shit my pants,
but I love their fucking tostadas status.
Have you heard that conspiracy
theory that Mcdonald's,
you know it says hundred percent beef
that that's an actual trademark name,
hundred percent and beef. Is
that for real? We're just not.
Don't they can say that? Then they can
get sued? No, no, no. It was like a,
it was like their beef.
They're called
beef even though it's 40% right. That's
the conspiracy theory. So I don't know.
I don't really know if that's true.
Is Mcdonald's is same as Taco bell in
terms of like what percentage of it is
actually beef up their chicken? The
one thing that's really weird about it,
that's not the one thing that's
fucked up about the beef.
You getting hamburger from the thousands.
Those cows can come from 10
different parts of the globe.
So you're eating the the cows from
China, Argentina, United States.
Who gives all his cows were killed and
killed. Then it's brought together.
So one cab,
Bro.
I don't give him my burner has come
from ice to know cow's name. I have to,
I'll tell you though,
I think the healthiest,
healthiest thing for you at
Mcdonald's doesn't make no oil.
Fish is made from real food
change. The label fishes. Awesome.
Have you had a MCRIB? Those are real
ribs. You know they take me to present,
rebuild. They take me and form
it as a fucking, is that true?
Let's read the Mcdonald Mcdonald things.
Not True. I love make that larger.
Please. I want a fish sandwich,
Eddie. Well, smaller again,
so it fits the screen.
There you go.
Whether it's a fascinating premise,
there is nothing to at Mcdonald's.
Hamburger patties in the u s are
made with 100% us da inspected beef.
They're cooked to prepare with salt,
pepper and nothing else. No preservatives,
no fillers to punk. So it's
pretty healthy. It's debunked.
How's that possible? That's 100%
what are your top of that site?
What is the title of it?
Our Mcdonald's hamburgers hundred percent
beef taco bell. Get on that train.
They're just like, Nah, fuck. And
they're like, fuck it. We just get,
you know it's Shitty for you. Yeah,
they're way worse than Mcdonald's.
Mcdonald's buys their meat from a company
called 100% beef. That's not true.
That's not true. Well that's the
conspiracy ball thing. It's false.
So it is.
Look man,
you could probably get beef pretty
God damn cheap if you do it that way.
Just grinded all day.
I still like del Taco and
all that stuff is so gross.
But if you go to a real taco spot bromine,
you have a at Mcdonald's,
Mcdonald's fuck up. I will fuck up an
egg mcmuffin and we'll fuck of it. I
think it's an egg. Here's the thing,
if you get egg mcmuffin with ham,
they really can't fuck with that.
You get that sausage.
Who knows what's in that shit on.
But if you get
curious now the eggs actually and lately
they that they make there what the egg
Mcdonald's said that they, that the
amount chickens and eggs they use now,
they don't have,
I think they don't use antibiotics.
The kick tinny eggs that are freshly
cracked in Mcdonald's restaurants.
That's impressed.
The chains.
Egg items such as scrambled eggs and
egg whites are made from liquid eggs.
But so that's what you go.
Will you go with the regular chicken
or you go with a regular egg?
Mcmuffins who doesn't get
egg on their egg muffin?
I'm gonna just get to the sausage
patty. Well, the sausage patties,
you don't know what you're getting
with that taste like bacon. No sausage.
White Chase. They're scientists and
they're working on tastes for real.
They do a good job on it. We're do a good
job soaked in syrup. What about that?
You're talking about, let me grill
McGriddle it's brilliant. It's brilliant.
It's candy. Candy had an fair
should. It's very good. I like it.
I feel good when I eat it. Who the
fuck whores flail fish filet of fish.
I love. I never had one. You're the
first person that we're talking about it.
It's like dessert now lunch.
They're very good. They're good.
And that should post that tartar sauce.
I send him the best cars in and out of
the best hamburgers right now. Five guys.
Pretty God damn good to have five guys.
Five guys would slice Jalapenos sued off.
Tell you fucked shake shack is very shaky.
Jack's delicious.
You got no shit dude. You can't
play does it? Fucking right.
Can't know where to have Sunday. No
fucking beef. Chicken sandwiches the best.
Which one? Chick-Filet it's good.
It's good. It's good. Fuck good.
That's pretty good chick.
Filets delicious.
They made their name off that God damn
sandwich and I'll take something else
cause I got pickles and stuff now shake
shack that Jalapeno smoked Jalapeno
Bacon Burger. Now get the fuck
Outta here right now. Cash.
I just get a whopper with cheese.
Ketchup only from campfire beef.
Cheap shit. You can't fuck with it bro.
I have to be fucking super hungry in
the middle of the desert on the way to
Fresno for me to fuck with King.
Be desperate to that stupid wouldn't
king that they had at that dumb ad.
I saw it enemies though. I'm
down with Wendy's. I love
Wendy's. I love their fries.
Wendy's on another level. See, I'm
a really burger king. Burger King.
When I'm done with the show him,
there's nothing else open.
I'll go to burger king.
You know what?
Get me two fucking whoppers ketchup
on over Mickey D's. Oh yeah.
With Wendy's. Beef has never frozen.
That's how they get you squared.
We worked at Mcdonald's for a,
with us for three weeks when I was a 17
year old and a bit, you were terrible.
We dropped the burgers and put it back
on the grill and we showed them son of a
man ruined people's fucked up when we
were younger. We did it by accident.
I didn't want to waste the food.
Whatever.
You know a good Italian sub with
like melted parmesan cheese.
Talking about the meatball
sub from subway. Jared go bro.
Tuna,
tuna
at subway. I'll fuck with that.
Yeah, but not from subway.
You're talking about a real subject.
Blimpie's
Deli.
Quizno's come on
guy.
You go to an Italian Deli in Boston or
New York and where they have the hands
hanging from the ceiling where the guys
at 90 year old guy can get that base
cities in Vancouver,
the basic cracked the fucking
place on mother as good as it gets,
have a red is shit down your throat.
It's delicious. It's unbelievable.
There's some spots bases. Unbelievable.
Why don't more people do that?
Like when you go to a real
Italian restaurant or real
Italian sub shop and you
get like sausage and peppers with tomato
sauce. Damn, I'm so good. You're like,
okay, who? Why don't they figure out how
to sell this more places? No, I know.
Quality is expensive, Bro.
It is, but it's so God damn.
You're like, okay, well all these
like little cheeseburger spots.
How come you can't have a sausage
peppers hoping in Hoboken,
New Jersey in the 90s all Italian.
You'd go to those fucking Dallas
and they'd had the water Mozzarella.
They're making it in the back.
They'd make the Mozzarella and they put
that shit on a, an Italian sub get, oh my.
What's that right there? Send genero
seats engineer's face. Yeah. Yeah.
That's a little little. And they
always have these big sausage vendors.
Just giant grill sausages laid out.
You're walking by and you get one
and immediately just delighted.
Just busted in your mouse. Oh
my God. Did the bread bread.
It's just got this density to
it. And you're like, Holy Shit.
You guys ever fuck with the
kitchen sink cookie? What's that?
The kitchen sink cookies. All ingredients
are in the cookie at Panera bread.
They got a cookie called the
kitchen sink. It's five bucks, dude.
This is a good thing. Only usually
fucking chocolate chip cookies.
I don't fuck with Colton
meal or cinnamon cookie.
It's gotta be a good
chocolate chip cookie. I mean,
maybe some peanut butter in there,
but kitchen sink has fucking
everything and it's addicting as fit.
You've got to be high, right? No, no, no,
no. You know what? There was a Panera,
Panera bread next to chipotle I,
so I go to chipotle and go get the salad.
No fucking no burrito. I'm going with the
south site clean. I clean it. Chipotle,
and then the Panera bread's
right next door. And I'm like,
should I just walk to my car and just
get in and drive the fuck away or am I
going to go next door and fuck
this all up and get a kitchen sink?
So I've always had to struggle.
I go to chipotle and I'm eating like an
Olympian at AAA and then I walk out and
sometimes they get in my car just fucking
burn rubber and I'm out. But it's,
it's been, uh, a problem of
mine. But luckily, luckily,
luckily I struggle with the
same. Seriously. I had a
salad. No, that's not it.
I had a salad and I walked out and I
was know I was on the fence of whether I
should get a kitchen sink. And I
said, fuck it. I'm going to get it.
And I walked next door and the
place closed down probably for like,
Holy Shit was a legit,
totally, I feel good now. Now there's,
I don't, I don't have a choice.
What are you showing us? These
are the rocks. Cheat meal cookies.
Have you seen him? He goes to the
flyers to some special place in Hawaii.
Just for them. They're like fun cooking.
It's like a cookie instead of cookies.
I eat
six ounces.
I'm going to one of the islands. What
are you doing out there and comedy son.
Damn. No, I'm going to in Hawaii, man.
Wow.
Who or some shit going
bro. Tollhouse cookies telling us
closer to the Philippines or something.
Right. Is it specific? Was it closer
to Hawaii or closer to the foot?
Closer to the, I think it's
closer to Hawaii. I think
it's like a thousand miles.
It's pretty far,
but how does anyone starving and yeah,
I know him. I know a Mexican spot.
It's like a legit, a Mexican spot.
Not that one I threw up at, right?
No, no, no. Remember that front one
Italian style. It's still there.
Yeah. We hit the bomb too hard.
We got a stomach. When was this?
Many, many, many years ago.
More than that.
More than 10.
More than 10 like 18 it was
hot as fuck during the day.
Empty stomach. We're about
to go eat, get some burritos,
and he wanted to stop at a
head shop and get a bong.
So he got them bomb and all yet. And
I was thirsty as fuck. It was hot.
We decided to hit the bottom before I
went to the burrito place and suburbs,
hottest fucking all he had in him. He
had a case of red bulls, right stomach.
I took two cause every little, so I took
to, that was, it was high. I was thirsty,
hit up, got gigantic
dragon head, this bond,
we walked, we walked
to caffeine, caffeine,
stomach empty sounds a big one.
That a real bad experience.
So we walk into the Burrito shop and
nobody was ever that. We'd walk and we
were always the only, the only people.
So it was like,
how the fuck are they making money?
Are they like bringing food from home?
You know what I mean? But anyways,
the room started spinning.
I thought like I was gonna throw up and
I just walked out of that place and just,
I needed to find a bush. And I, as
soon as I walked off like 20 yards,
I saw Bush and I thought, I'm
not going to make it, man.
And I made a fucking beeline for the bush,
but then I collapsed halfway
through on my hands and knees,
just puking all over the sidewalk
and I'm trying to drag myself.
And then I puked here.
I took a couple more crawls,
steps had puked again three or four times.
I finally got to the Bush,
had a couple more, a couple more,
uh, um, uh, ounces for the bush.
And then I felt great after I
threw up, I felt great, but man,
I left the crime scene all over there.
Go back and eat again.
I left the place. He's, he's freaking
out. He's like, I got to go outside.
I gotta check, I gotta find a Bush,
I'm going to Puke. I'm like, no way.
He goes outside of,
I wasn't sure,
like, what do I do? Do I order the
fleet? Do I help them? Do I wait? So,
and then I was like, how serious
is this? And I went outside.
He's on his hands and knees.
Pukes flying out of him.
He's crawling behind the corner to what?
He's his work and he's hurl and into
the bushes. Wait, this is ridiculous.
Jimmy Chin. We're barbecued.
I mean, so the whole is this,
this isn't the same Mexican place. You
were just talking about different stories.
This the other place, they don't even
speak English to them to take you guys to,
they didn't even speak English.
I'm driving. It's phenomenal.
I'm driving from central park.
I'm driving from Calabasas is just down
the PCH and it's just a windy, you know,
through Topanga Canyon kind of,
well,
I had Jimmy Burke in the car
who doesn't drive in cars.
He lives in New York City. So he is
used to walking or riding his bike.
He never drives in cars.
So as we're going down,
I'm just taking it for granted and I'm
just seeing zing. Zing, zing though he,
and he goes like this, hey,
we get to the bottom. He goes,
has Baba you gotta pull over
right now. I go, why? He goes,
I think I'm going to die.
Go. What happened? He goes,
you're swerving. He got out.
He was on his hands and knees and we
waited there for 45 minutes cause he
couldn't get back in the car.
That's how fucked up and threw
up and just kept throwing up.
Brian Killen you ever think you
drive like an asshole? No. No.
He just wasn't used to it. Jesus.
Maybe I just hugged you ever.
If you're super sick, if I'm on my
phone in the car, you a driver to,
you're going to back on my phone.
I can read those either. Don't.
Don't try to read a book with ears.
I get so sick when I do that.
You have to put my phone down
to concentrate on the horizon.
Just slowly dissipate, but just focus
on the horizon. I get so sick with that.
I can read in a car if you
ever got seasick and I can
read. I can fuck what? Whoa,
whoa dude. While you're driving or what?
Someone else, I get sucked in the back.
So
the idea that you would be driving
one of those cars and it runs out of
batteries is what scares me the most.
I've had it happen where a, that's a lie.
It never happened,
but I was having a cigarette and I just
made it into my driveway. I remember.
Yeah,
I remember we were someone you have to
stop and charge it to look up a charge
plus zero gets you. How long? Uh,
I've only like couple miles on zero. So
you don't want to fuck with it. But I, I,
it happened to me twice very
recently where I pulled into my,
to Sony and they plugged it in.
I was zero and zero,
but soon it takes forever. It takes
forever to fucking charge. Fill up.
Yeah, man, it's a bummer for
hours, you know, we'll get you,
you need six hours to get a hundred for
a hundred percent. Really seven hours.
Right. Wow. Yeah. Depending on,
and if you were on the charger,
if you got that Tesla charger,
you got an hour here,
an hour even less. Can you get
this at your crib? That's like,
I saw them at the movie theater the other
day. Yeah. They can't get those movies.
You see, uh, we saw the, um, the
new record mouth reg urology. Yes.
It's very,
take my kid out of my weird though,
Sarah Silvermans divorce voice to this
little girl. And so obviously Sarah sub,
she's great in it. Yeah.
But it's so obviously her to
me, I'm like, Oh, Hey Sarah.
I liked her one hour. I saw half of it
anyway. I really liked the shit. She all,
she seen her murder.
She's such a good comp store.
Silver. Very, very good comment. Yeah. I
think maybe the best, best female female.
That's what I mean. Yeah. Dude.
Trevor Noah's special on Netflix.
It's funny as fuck isn't it?
It's really funny. I heard
mixed reviews. Really? Yeah.
Since you said that. But I mean,
you know, it's all, it's awesome.
Jackie made me laugh. It's awesome. Type
of a car. Brian judges you. It's true.
Maybe you don't like the same humor
now. Isaiah fury the purple car. Uh,
it's just like two peacocks.
Peacocky it's just like, hey,
he's the way he dresses. He just,
I know what he's going to do.
Like I know that that one Porsche wasn't
enough and he's like, I got a picture,
it'll just, he'll just send me
a random picture. And I'm like,
don't you fucking do it.
Of course he needs the purple.
Do you think if you got rid of this Tesla,
and I know you want to have a car that
has a back seat where you could take your
kids and you drove a nine 11.
I've driven one.
When was the last one I drove Arnold
Schwartzenegger nine 11 Porsche turbo.
When was that? As he put it up for
sale and my friend and he said,
I got a surprise for you in 88
or some shit. Two thousands,
2000. It's a great car. But the
problem is it's, it's, it's just a lot.
I think it was a stick, you know, and
traffic and shit. I'm just too lazy.
I'm not a driver. You have to order a
stick. Most of them don't. This head, uh,
this had a special interior.
Like it was beautiful car. Yeah.
What I'm saying is it causes drove one.
If you drove like a nine 11 and automatic
one, amazing. You would love it,
I'm sure. But then again, I really
love that test. I think my lease is up.
So the question is to really
get a Panamera. What do I
get? When's the lease up?
March.
But I can trade it in or writing.
Well you know there's benefits to both,
right?
There's benefits of the electric thing
is it's pretty dope. It's fast as shit.
Yeah. Off the line. There's no gears.
Right. So just like there's no shifting.
You don't care about speed.
I like pickup.
I like pickup and I liked the fact that
it parks itself and I liked the fact
that it drives itself. And
once the traffic, if I'm in
traffic I'll go like that.
I hit this thing and I just stand.
The editors drives in bumper to bumper
and I never have to touch the wheel.
So yeah, I hear you now, but you're
going slow. You're not stop and start.
That's tiring. It's annoying. Yeah.
Have your hand on the wheel a little bit
lightly and just, you can read a book.
I don't know about that
drive the goddamn color.
Once you have cars driving for you,
it's the future.
But we're all going to be
eventually it will. Yeah.
Kids aren't gonna get drivers driver
license or way down. There's like Uber's,
why would we drive you old fuck
really? Uber everywhere. Yeah.
Driver's in getting drivers. Uber, Uber.
It's is a little dangerous because
those Uber drivers is weird as fuck.
Gonna have driverless. Uber isn't, then
we're just going to get in no way. You're
going to let a car drive itself like on
this new Tesla has so many cameras.
Like it just parked for me.
Like the download I, I went, I called my
buddy goes, cause you know this works.
My Buddy Jeff and I go, no. And he goes,
watch this. And I pushed this park.
I stood there, it parked it
parallel, parked so fast and well,
so much better. I didn't have to do, I
sat there and it just went. I was like,
are you made me feel like less of a man?
But you get lazy.
It's just easy. After a while.
That's ridiculous. Hit a button.
That's so sounds like what people probably
said when the printing press came out.
I know you're not going to write
your words. You're not going to get
no, no. I'm not talking about
pride or anything like that. I'm,
you're going to be driving
on the freeway 65 miles.
That's eventually she's going to
get so good. No, I don't. I don't.
That would make me eventually fall.
That makes me way more than other people.
There's so many accident, dumb
asses. They're reading their phone.
It was some lady should someone else
car that I'm in reading hard that I'm in
because she didn't know.
Traffic just goes in the Middle Lane,
middle and just stopped dead.
A woman I work with,
her mother was killed by a
distracted rights and driving killed,
killed her mother. They say it's
going to take over drunk driving.
Everything takes him driving to be number.
Every time I see someone
driving fucked up,
I always pull up next to him and
they're always on their phone. Oh,
it's like 89 90% of the time.
It's not the other.
It's just people just should.
They should make it so that your phone
doesn't work while you're driving. Right.
You're throwing shot this an
option in the new iPhones,
there's an option to locks. Locks
you out of everything. Yeah.
When he takes those. I'm driving right
now and we'll give you a tech. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, one of these days it
might be mandatory. Right? Well,
she cannot be on your
phone while you're driving,
unfortunately by take a tragedy. That
is, well that is a law. That is a lot
good hands free system.
You can do a lot of shit.
Like I can press the little button on my
steering wheel and say Call Eddie Bravo
and it'll call. You can, I'll
say tech teddy probably read it.
Will read text to you to read text.
See if you have apple carplay. Yup.
But then the problem is if
you started making rechecks,
what does that read? Read?
Brian said Dick Pic. Yeah.
What'd you like to reply?
No. Okay. That's kind of cool.
It's kind of weird though. It's,
it's, it's, they're going to have
something. This is whatever this is.
This is going to be nothing compared
to whatever they settle on 10 years.
When the fuck are we getting flying cars
that's never going to take it's spine.
Remember your joke about it? Your
bitch. I haven't heard it. It's great.
It's on your new,
you know,
2006 no one or two.
Nobody else did, but it didn't
get on something. Oh, okay.
I went from 99 to 2005
there's a lot. There was a long
gap or I didn't film anything.
That's where that step. It's from 99 to
2005 special. Yeah. Why'd you do that?
Too busy. That was the fear factor.
Gotcha. You weren't grinding with comedy,
so you know
we're supposed to have those.
I was doing a lot of spots
at the store 30 years ago,
traveling on chips on
chips like 1978 1980 that,
that um, jet packs back then and
we still haven't mastered yet,
but they're getting pretty good though.
I have suggest patios. Yes. I have seen,
yeah, that they're getting
better now. I've seen it.
I saw a guy in the NFL invest half
of his salary in the flying cars.
This was in 2000 throw. No.
Yeah, he's not doing well.
God didn't work out flying cars. Jesus
Christ. Yeah. That's not going to happen.
I'm going to get ahead of the curve.
Oh,
just something like that. Getting
off the ground, getting approved,
getting licensed, not dropping out
of the sky. Can we structure 80?
We didn't think, you know, in 2018
we'd still have cars with rubber tires,
engines and basically the same thing.
Some countries are
making gas cars by 2020.
But what the Craig leading is,
what are you saying this? Yeah, no,
they're not going to release the saddle
gas cars. Yeah. Don't make them illegal.
Oh, what about retro cars? Like are you
allowed to keep your car from like 1980?
I'm not sure. China, China
in one year decided that uh,
their air was terrible and one year they
basically said that you're going to use
natural gas instead of like a coal
and stuff like that in your home.
And, uh, I think it was what it was trying
to have the advantage of just going,
hey, all you billion plus people no more.
And they changed it in a fucking year.
They just literally just
change the infrastructure
so that they'll be the first
ones because they don't think electric.
All of China. Yeah, look that up.
We still have coal plants and shit. Well
they do but, but people were using, uh,
things like coal and gas
are fuel to cook their food,
to heat their homes and, and basically
the president said, Nah, natural gas,
clean burning gas.
No more changed it in a year.
There is a lot better because
the area was pretty bad,
but they said the air
was the worst in Beijing.
One thing about UC in Beijing is
nothing but unfinished buildings.
They'll build 20 of the same exact
looking building in one area and it's so
ugly.
These giant buildings and that's the
landscape and they're empty or just cranes
and they're not working. They
overbuilt a lot. Why'd they do that?
They have ghost cities.
They have huge cities where nobody lives
in them because they were essentially
saying,
let's just build as many cities as we can,
but they didn't have the population to
move them in or the or the economy to
support that city. It's like North
Korea to have a bunch of empty created.
Is that a,
all somebody has to take a product
of communism versus capitalism cause
capitalism, they would have had to
have some sort of financial plans. Yes.
It's a command. It's a command economy.
Right, so, so why not just create jobs,
create jobs. If everybody's working,
just build a bunch of buildings.
Nobody has to live in them,
but just as long as we got people going
in downtown La, it's kind of like that.
They're building that new skyscrapers
all the Goddamn time for selling the shit
out of them. Yeah. That's the difference.
A marketplace dictates you have dealt
with developers to take huge risks and
they say, I'm going to build this in the
hopes that I can fill that retail space,
office space. China, Ned does
not the same pressures. You know,
China's an economy of influence to a
lot of times you're not doing business
unless you've got, you know, connections
with the people that okay, your permits,
et Cetera.
I mean fuck was so lucky.
We don't live in a dictatorship like that.
Like if you're stuck under the boot of
something like North Korea and you stuck
and we could,
could've got a shit roll
the dice of course born in
there about an all the time.
Especially because I lived in those
countries as a kid. Right. You, you, you,
we take a lot of our freedoms for granted,
but at the same time they're always
under threat. You know, I think from,
from companies like the fact that so much
information is it's concentrated in so
few companies like Facebook,
like Google, I worried they have,
yes, they have critical. That's the real
issue. The real issue is that they have,
they lean politically and they almost
should be completely neutral and just
allow or not allow things based on
whether or not it violates the rules.
But that's not really the
case. No. And also the way,
the way campaign finance works,
like the way you have to have money,
it's changing a little, but if you
don't have money as a politician,
you better say what your financing to
the people that are financing and commit
campaign. They'll tell you, they'll
give you a sheet on what to say.
If you don't do that, you're
not in Congress. The next
time you were out you, you,
you know you,
you,
you have to listen to the people that
put you there and that's a problem.
It costs a lot of money to get elected.
It's just you.
You've got to have very clear rules if
you're going to have rules in terms of
like what you can and can't say.
They have to apply to everyone
regardless of race, regardless of gender,
ethnicity,
and they don't like,
one of the things that Bret Weinstein
tweeted the other day that I retweeted was
some woman who, who wrote all white people
are racist and she just went on this,
this anti white screed. Like you
just can't say that. That's dumb.
That's a dumb generalization.
And it's racist.
And you don't think it's racist because
it's racist against white people,
but it's racist.
It's so stupid that you allow that,
but you don't allow racism
against other races.
What's funny is that they're
thinking the same way.
Their methodology is the same as the
people they're criticizing. Yeah.
Susan has cracked ribs.
Is that what you think?
It's how you think that makes
it more of a difference. Right.
So you're thinking like a racist.
I know that you have a different kind
of racism, but it's still racist. Well,
they think it's justified their shitty
way of doing the math. Yeah, it's not,
they're not that smart. That's the
other thing is that one's about,
it's been sitting there for three
hours. It's coffee, but the,
but the way you get elected, stay
elected as you, you tow the Utah though.
Like if you're,
if you want to have sort of Anti Wall
Street legislation, certain things.
So swipe fees, swipe fees
on your ATM, that was,
that's a huge issue and it doesn't
affect a lot of us, but it affects, uh,
corporations, a bank's bottom
line. And that becomes, you better.
You better vote favorably or you're
going to, you're going to have a problem.
But I think more and more Americans are
realizing that money in politics is a
big problem. It is just how the fuck
would you ever get it out? I Dunno.
It's always been that way. The question
is, does your government represent you?
Right, right. So gerrymandering
and how campaigns are financed,
drives me nuts out quiet.
Eddie is turn all I'm thinking
about distinguished gentlemen.
Remember Eddie Murphy when
he became a politician?
I don't remember that one is
old school man. I see that one.
I might not have said that might be the
one that I've never said he wanted to be
a politician because they
found out the damn that's,
that's where you make the money. So he,
well you man, Tony Latex, just like,
you know, just taking bribes and all
that shit. But then he gets a conscience.
He does the right thing at the end.
But a congressmen spans a US congressman
spends between 30 and 70% of his time
or her time on the phone to people they
don't know, trying to raise money. Okay,
so and you're not allowed to
do it on government property.
So what you do is you go across the
street, you're sitting in your car,
you can go across to you in the capital,
they're in their car and
they're making phone calls,
they're given a list and you make a phone
call and you spend 30 to 70% of your
time doing that to raise money.
There's something wrong with that.
That's kind of fucked up,
but it's, you got to do that.
Whenever I hear people talk
too much about politics,
even myself included my own words,
I'm like,
you're talking about like a rigged game.
It's like you're,
it's like you're talking
about pro wrestling.
It's like you're talking about something
that's you pretending that it's real,
but you know what you know,
you know,
of course the government
is corrupt as fuck,
but when you're talking
about stuff like that,
like it are the election's
rigged or do our votes count?
The one thing that I learned from this,
this,
these midterms is that if your vote
didn't count and it was an and a,
it's all decided like pro wrestling.
Then there wouldn't be all this voter
fraud and all these computers that can,
you know, I'm talking to them. I'm not
sure I'm going to have to get a boat.
I'm talking about the way once you're in
office, the way things get. Nothing. No,
no, no. I get it. But what I'm saying
is from, from uh, the elections,
you see that your vote's do matter.
There's a lot of corruption and fraud
going on. But if it was all rigged,
like WWE, they wouldn't need to
do all that was, you're right.
So it's still, it's still
the real system, right?
Because a lot of people think it's not
a real system. Like it doesn't matter.
They already decided and they're just
going to put them in. No. The way they,
they actually decide is,
is they decide who they're
going to rig the machines for,
but the vote still counts. You just got to
make sure that there's no, uh, you know,
shenanigans going on votes. Right.
Certainly do count. But what would,
where it gets really squirrely, and
this is where politics get goofy, is in,
why do politicians do what they do?
Do they do what they do to support
the people or do they do what they do?
Because special interest groups of
infant to way more. But not only that,
here's what's really, wow. So, so
Capitol Hill, when you're in Congress,
they call that the farm team. Because
in cabinet, hell, you spent six years,
seven years, let's just say, or a senator.
Now, when you're a senator for, I dunno,
10 years, when you're on capital hill for
as a congressman for six, for 10 years,
you develop real connections
and relationships with
government officials who
make decisions.
You also understand how government works.
You understand who's actually
influencing who. So now what do you do?
So let's say you lose an election,
or let's say you decide,
I bet I made my hundred and 60 grand a
year, can't really live on that money.
You go to k street,
you join a lobbying firm and,
and because you've been there
for six or nine or 10 years,
you know a lot of people and
that lobbying farm goes, hey,
we'll pay $1 million now.
And all you gotta do is drive
to Capitol Hill every day.
Get in there and influence,
use your connections so that we,
we can get what we want from government.
So corporations hiring lobbying
firms to lobby for their bottom line.
So now you're working
to influence government.
And the problem is when you're
in Congress, you know that,
you know you have a job waiting.
If you can make great connections and
now Washington becomes an economy of
influence. That's the game,
right? Yes. I'm fucking,
you gotta have a Lawrence Lessig on
your Goddamn podcast. He can explain it.
He's a Harvard professor
and that motherfucker keep
telling me about the podcast
you did with him. He'll break it
down. I did. Yeah. Listen to that.
I'll say I sent it to you. I think
it's Lawrence Lessig. He's, he's,
he breaks it down.
He wrote a book called Republic lost
and he's got a couple of Ted talks.
But that dude,
yes.
And basically he said your government
doesn't represent you and here's why.
Here's how it works.
When he breaks it down and you go,
it's simple the way he breaks it down
cause he's a constitutional scholar at
Harvard and you're like, fuck it, the
kid. And what he said was fascinating.
He said, Washington's a place
where even if you're a good person,
you must behave in a corrupt
manner if you want to survive.
And that's when you have problems
when good people have to behave.
Corruptly yeah,
yeah.
The bright side of all of that then
fed the bright side of all that is uh,
the fact that there is like people
getting suicided and bribery going on,
that that means that there's hope,
that there's good people inside the
government that you got to watch you gotta
your ass. You know, we're going to have,
we got to hire someone to kill you
because we don't want to go to jail.
So the fact that all that's down it
kill you, they can just get you out.
Or what I'm saying is the fact that
there is all that bribery and suiciding,
that means that there's good people
in there that are, are going after,
uh, the bad people. But to
me, I look at the bright side.
I used to think there was no hope.
I used to think fuck am like when,
when the bushes were an office,
Clinton, Obama, I was like,
I didn't pay attention to shit.
I just said they're all corrupt.
It's all rigged and it's all, you know,
there's nothing you could do about it.
But um, you know, over the
last couple of years, you know,
since Trump got into office now
I'm like paying attention. My,
there are some good people trying to
do some good shit. Like Trey Gowdy.
Listen to that motherfucker.
Trey Gowdy is a bad motherfucker.
What are you talking about? Gates? No
politician with the congressmen. Oh Man.
They're great people going
after the bad people.
That's why there needs to be
bribes and suiciding and blackmail.
The reason there's black males,
because there's good people in there.
If everybody was bad, they would.
Why would you blackmail any,
the problem is it's really subtle
the way they can get you out though.
Because when your donors are
telling you which way to vote,
you're you as a politician going there
with all your ideas and you can't vote
your conscience. There's a lineup
and she got a lot of bad shit.
You've got to show the money. You're
preaching to the choir over here. I'm not,
I'm not going to defend. So you fix
that. So, so Lawrence Lessig has,
one of the ideas he talks about
is anonymous donations. So,
so watch your a politician.
I'm a corporation.
I give your a or an eye through a
super PAC or whatever it might be.
I give your campaign a lot of money.
Now you're a regular dude.
You're not corrupt.
But human beings,
when somebody gives them a
real hand when they needed it,
you can't help but to feel a little
indebted. Of course. What if all,
what if there are two ideas?
What if you add a voucher system with
all of us were given a certain amount of
money every election cycle and we were
allowed to anonymously to give that money
to whoever we thought was a viable
candidate. It'd be anonymous.
Or what if all donations were anonymous?
What if you didn't,
if you couldn't say who it was from,
but if you know you've got a lot of stuff
from GE or you know you've got a lot
of stuff from Lockheed and there's a bill
that comes up for Saudi Arabia to buy
a bunch of tanks or
whatever or or weaponry,
it's going to be very hard for you
to vote against that. And if you do,
those people that got you in power
last time aren't going to get you.
Empower the, basically figured
out a way to make bribing legal.
This is just the way it works,
Bro.
Take care of you and you
add money to your campaign,
but then don't exactly tell you
what to do, right? But you know,
read the book to read is republic lost
fucking good because it on the audio. Yes.
It's amazing.
And get,
get Lawrence Lessig on your God damn
podcast to break it down. All right,
let's do it relaxed.
I get excited about it because when you
say campaign finance reform is so boring,
right? Did I hear that? I go like this.
Ooh, I've had a book, two books on it.
I'm like, oh darn, I get bored. I get
tired right away. But it's so important.
They've got to figure out some way
to stop these giant corporations from
influencing politicians. They've got to
find some way it's gotta become illegal,
influenced your money shows and everybody,
there's money to be made no matter
what the idea is that they want.
So much so that anything
that threatens that money,
the real true marketplace they want, they
want to put the fucking brakes to that.
But you still have a kid supposed
to cancel each other out though. So,
so ideally it's nothing wrong with
petition your government that's in the
constitution.
So you can lobby your government,
it's called petitioning your guide,
but her laptop donating money to
your campaign. That's where it,
that's where citizens United comes. Isn't
lobbying illegal in some countries? Uh,
probably the problem with lobbying,
so says boy countries and legal
and I think maybe a Holland.
I think so. I think lobbying
cause that's what a, but lobbying,
the with making lobbying illegal is,
it's part of free speech.
That's what it was ruled in the
Supreme Court. So citizens United.
So in other words,
if I want to give money to you,
you're a politician and you and I want to,
I want Eddie Bravo to be president,
right? I should be able to exercise
my right as a citizen and support you,
which means you want. So I want to amplify
your voice. That means you need money.
So to tell me I can't give money to the
person I like is a restriction of free
speech.
And that I think is,
I think that was the citizens
United Supreme Court knows
there's another problem.
The other problem is when
subjects like this get brought up,
and this is one of the most important
subjects that we could ever discuss,
like how our world gets run. I get bored
as fuck. I know you get bored as fuck.
He turns out, I've been starting up
the wall for the last 30 minutes.
I understand it's you don't want to have,
you don't want to have to play.
It affects all of us. Do you want to be
like these I'm leaves over here dude.
You going to do so into politics ever?
I'ms depo changes.
I love it. It's like game of Thrones, but
it's for real and it affects your life.
It does affect your life.
Real Shit is real game of Thrones going
on right now and it's so entertaining to
find out what the fuck instead of watching
it Goddamn TV show that does nothing
for your life you're at.
It's really like game of Thrones
really going on right now.
If they pay attention,
attendance problem with John,
season hundred and 11 watched TV
shows so that I could just have fun.
Yeah. I'm not saying don't do
that. I'm not saying don't do that,
but I don't think you can do both.
Those things freak me the fuck out.
And you can do both.
You can do both.
But if you really start paying attention
too much to politics and I have a bunch
of friends that are really into policy,
especially right now, and they could talk,
let me ask all of you this.
So,
so as far as like not standing
out of politics or whatever,
what if this is where it comes down to?
We off kids here,
so now there is a legislative agenda,
whatever it might be,
and it's an agenda that says we want to,
we want to teach your kids something
like let's just say because the social
scientists and academia wins their way.
It gets into the air.
Politicians was happens all the time
and politicians say all schools,
public schools at least where my kids go
are going to teach that there's a zero
biological difference or zero
difference between men and women.
Oh and by the way,
ready evolution is a theory and we're
going to put it on the same standings as
creationists theory too.
I eat school board in Kansas I think
at one point and had that going on.
There are the frame each saying
the same people that say,
I'm just saying what happens?
What happens if you, if you,
if you stay out of this
debate and the wrong people,
when they push their ideas forward,
which usually have a political agenda,
you might be faced with a situation where
somebody is trying to educate your kid,
kid in things that you just not only
disagree with factually incorrect so that
this happens. This is where it
starts getting personal. Yeah.
It can get real weird. Like there was
this thing from nature of the other day
that,
uh,
I retweeted cause Bret
Weinstein Weinstein had,
uh,
brought it up and it was like,
this is really disturbing that these
people were making this distinction.
It was talking about the difference
between biological sex and uh, and real,
I don't want to misquote it,
so I'll find out the exact thing.
But there's essentially promoting social
justice principles over scientific
principles. And it's supposed to be a
company that specializes in science,
right?
So instead of just being scientific,
there's scientific with a very clear
progressive political twist to it.
And you're like, well, just
because something's in convenient,
it doesn't mean it's incorrect.
Just because something's uncomfortable
doesn't mean it's not true. Right?
And there's things that you might have
your own personal beliefs and values and
ethics, but that's not what we're counting
on. When you're a science journal,
we're counting on just facts. That's
it. And they're not doing that.
Did you see the,
I think I sent you guys are to thing to
say this proposal has no foundation in
science is nonsense. The genitals. So
this is what it is. Like go to the pit,
pull up the nature one first.
I could read that the u s editorial,
the u s department of Health and human
services proposes to establish a legal
definition of whether someone is male
or female based on the genitals they are
born with.
This proposal has no foundation in
science and should be abandoned.
And this is the journal Nature though.
So the problem with that is what
Bret Weinstein very succinctly says,
like to say in quotes, this proposal
has no foundation in science,
which is what they said he
says is nonsense. The genitals.
One one is born with show overwhelming
correlation with one self assessed gender
as predicted by evolutionary theory.
If we grant nature's claim,
we condemn the study of
complex phenomena to a dark.
There you go and there's the
class. Exactly. Sample and
nature should know better,
but they have a political agenda.
Where'd that come from?
They were influenced by forces
probably on the radical left in this.
In this instance, there are other
sports is on the other side.
That's where the wind is
going and if you support that,
you get way more love than you get
hate, right? There's currency to it.
You've lived finger you as prestige where
the wind's going to say that there's
no correlation is fucking bananas
were all men and that's controversial.
It's controversial to say it well.
It's just a lot of nonsense going on
right now that I think will eventually be
sorted out once the dust settles, but I
think this is just a wave of information.
It goes left,
it goes right.
Everybody's battling it out and because
people are more concerned with their
side winning than they
are with actual facts.
A lot of really stupid ideas get supported
and instead of objectively analyzed
for whether or not they contain Tris,
push back with kids though. So my buddy,
my buddy's son is 15 and he was like,
it's all about gender and,
and you know,
educating you on gender and high
school people choose their pronouns.
So when you're in college,
my nephew who was in college where I
dealt with 18 years old, they said,
I'd say your name and,
and please tell us what pronoun you
would like to be referred to class. Yes.
Right. At first, first day or so.
So now the kids, now the kids,
now the kids though, as they're being
taught this by their fucking teachers,
cause they're kids, they're like the
fuck out of here. So my friend goes,
look at that and look at,
look at butterflies and the
beautiful and his son goes,
Dad, do you have any idea how
hurtful it is that butterfly,
you have no idea what that
butterflies gender is.
And they're all fucking around now.
So if there's push back on that shit,
well you know, you can't get
to create some pushback kids.
So some cause we can see there's some
really influenced people easily influenced
people that are adopting
all the stars. Wait, yours.
So than it was when we were growing. Of
course, even if there's, especially in La,
indoctrination is the right word.
You can get kids to believe in anything.
I use some MK Ultra and my son
too. I said, you know what?
I'm going to make him a Cleveland
browns fan. We flew to Cleveland,
the Cleveland browns and all he
wanted was a baker, Mayfield Jersey.
That's the one be like, Dad, I'm like
fucking work once and be like, like dead.
But that's what he likes.
But that's what happens.
You got into Cleveland browns on one trip.
He's,
it's hard though to keep a theory going
that doesn't really have any basis in
science. At the end of the day it's,
it's kind of banking a physical.
I don't think they're very smart time.
I think their political now,
I don't think they're very smart and
I don't think there's scholarship.
There's this deep men,
women people born as men,
but think they're women. People
born as women, cattleman,
people that think they're both, that's
five. It's very rare. What else?
They said there's like 60 of them
are 78 different gender pronouns,
but that's because no one has agreed
on what the gender Pronoun should be.
So if you decide that yours is
I are and I said, no, mine is z.
Y. R. E like to explain,
it's an obsession. What it is, there's,
there are people that want to be special.
This is a big part in whatever you got
to go to. He's going to be Spanish.
If you're a guy, come on.
What do you got? Take courses.
I know you think you're a guy. You know
what? I know you think you're a guy,
but we're going to, you're going
to, you know what? For sure.
Harris said that I fucking loved.
He said right now the one thing to keep
in mind is that being offended is not an
argument and it's not a virtue.
So you can't just shut the conversation
down because you're offended and you're
taking issue with what I say.
That ain't an argument and it
sure as fuck ain't a virtue,
but that's what's going on. When, what's
her name? Heather Mcdonald's at her name.
She was speaking at a, she was speaking
at a college and there was a law student.
He was just giving you the finger the
whole time and all she was trying to do is
talk about, you know, something that was
based in science and Heather MacDonald.
What's her name? No, she's a,
she's a professor at journalists,
a professor of journalism I think.
And uh,
she's a very reasonable kind of like
clear, I can't remember matter man.
People are struggling so hard to find
things to be offended at that they're
pointing at targets that
aren't viable and the,
they're throwing all their weight into
it and then when it doesn't work they
back out and they try someone new. That's
right. You know, Christina Hoff summers,
you were some of the things that she did
where she was trying to speak and they
were shouting or going and making all
this noise in the crowd trying to bu or
off the stage. They try to silence people
because it's something that you can do.
You can get it done because
they're afraid of their ideas.
They don't think they're [inaudible]
committee game man. It's a game.
They're on one side, she's in the
other, it's a road for the browns.
She's with the Raiders, right? That's
what it is. Teams. It's 100%, which is,
what are your feelings
on the caravan situation?
What do you guys think about that?
Desperate people from all the people
that are getting in here every day.
Like what is this a full, it's a fake
thing. We're supposed to be painting.
Exactly happened with the Caribbean.
So they're making a big publicity event
out of these people that want to come to
America. They came from, they want asylum,
but they came from
[inaudible], [inaudible] and
this other gang are the big
employers there. If you don't join them,
you get your family killed. Nice guys.
And I think that, uh,
these people are desperate.
They're essentially refugees from
a place that's intolerable live,
but they're making it this really big
political deal. It's very publicized,
total.
And apparently then always walking.
Sometimes they get in the vans and
people drive in place and let them in.
I don't know who you'd say that we
shouldn't let them in or we should,
we'll load them in. This is what I'm
saying. I'm saying what's the issue?
Well yeah we definitely don't.
People don't want them if they're
illegal immigrants. Right.
But what's interesting to me is like if
you come from Cuba, you can just come.
Yeah. You if you get on a boat
and he get over here in America,
but like you made it bro. Come on in. If
you tried from Guatemala, Nah, sorry son.
Ronald Patch at dirt. Find another.
Don't take carpool because as a man,
because it sounds really bad,
but it's, it's fascinating.
Double murders in New York and there's
really made an agreement that anybody
who's trying to escape the kind of shitty
situation they have in Cuba will allow
that. Oh I got you. I got so loud
that Columbia, I mean if you,
if you're Yoel and you come over
from Cuba. Yes, that's true. Yeah.
Cause your comments,
we'll take you.
But people think that like all Mexicans
are like for the caravan and to,
you know, we want them,
you know, that's not true.
Most Mexicans are like immigration
in another country. You,
I ain't getting on welfare.
You know what I mean?
Mexicans ain't down for that caravan.
They want them turned away too.
It's a complicated emotional
issue, man. It's like,
I always do this joke
where I believe in borders,
but I'd be a shitty border control agent,
right?
Like I do think borders are reasonable,
but I have nobody gets over.
And then I'd be like, oh, the
kids, fuck it. Come on on. Right.
I think Americans feel that
way at that. You know, it's a,
it's a hard to live in a gated community.
No. Okay. I mean, yes. All right. No,
it is, it's like the idea
that there's a real country,
that there's a place where you can go in
a place where you can't go and like you
have to have papers and they make
a cross this line in the dirt,
like they've set up fences and borders.
Well,
the surface needs reason
that exists, right? I mean,
if you think about the United States,
right?
The United States essentially
is not just a country,
it's a collection of different areas,
right?
In each different area has
its own culture, their own
almost their own language.
You know,
the way they talk and Florida way fucking
different than the way they talk in
Maine. It's really weird.
It's all the same language,
but it's almost like they're separate
little countries and we travel amongst
each other. No problem. And you're
allowed to, you're allowed to bail out of,
I'm going to try and to Vegas for a while.
I'm going to get me a job at the casino.
Nobody cares.
You're fine as long as you're honest,
one patch of dirt.
But the reason why we don't allow all the
other patches that dirt to do the same
thing and everybody just flow freely
is because there's some spots that just
don't have it good at all.
And we want those people to stay there.
Although you haven't thought,
although your spot you haven't fixed,
you know what the connected extra spot,
but you know what the connective
tissue is for Americans besides the,
even though that's true,
the connective tissue that I think a lot
of countries don't have is that the one
thing we have gone for it. Even if it's,
even if it's a myth for a lot of people,
the one thing all Americans
have gone for him is,
is now is the idea that there's
a chance if I do the right thing,
I may be poor now American, but I could
be a fucking millionaire. Their control.
Yeah, for sure and shit is so, and
but that's what keeps the sort of,
that's what I have coming from
running from creating a revolution.
But if we lose that, if we let people
start thinking that's not for them.
Let everybody, right, right. You can't,
you can let everybody in from Kentucky.
If everybody from Kentucky
decided to move to La,
we would just have to deal with it.
Lots of America, they got citizenship.
That's what I'm saying.
Like,
it's not the reason why we
can't have world citizens.
Obs to some places suck too hard.
You don't want to nationalism.
I'm not saying that it's good or bad,
I'm just looking at it as a thing right
now. If I had to say, do I like it?
Honestly,
I think the whole world as
the human beings as a race
would be way better off if
everybody could move where it's good.
And then we would figure out why.
There's too many people where it's good
and then he'll settle down and you move
to a better spot. And then eventually
even out. The reason why ever happened,
but we never even reason why Tesla in
segregated areas don't advance like these
people in Sentinel Island. So kind
of a fucked up example. So in Taiwan,
they're not going anywhere like this is,
they're wearing leaves over there.
Dick for six.
Do they do Joe?
Really European Union, by the
way. You and I are morons. Okay.
If we were living on that island, we
would be having leaves over our Dick too.
It's not like, oh, I'm just going to
vet a satellite, these fucking morons.
Like we don't know how
to do any of that stuff.
So we would be with them just with a
greater understanding of what's possible.
But what you just said,
it's happening in the European Union.
I mean that's why a lot of Polish people
come out to the UK and they come back
and you know,
and there's also what they're doing now
with immigration is freaking a lot of
people out because they're allowing so
many people of different cultures to come
in and then there's cities become more
multicultural than they are English.
And then it gets real weird.
The other problem is that
when you have chain currency,
currency is used to be based on the
productivity of their citizenry, right?
So when you have currency,
everybody has the same currency,
which means it's all value.
The same thing.
Problem is that people in Spain are
not as productive as people in Germany,
for example.
So the German goods and services should
be worth more or the dollar there that
the euro there should be
worth more than it is. Say,
you know space better when the state has
more power than the, than the Fed. Well,
it's like countries. That's basically
what, because the argument is,
is we're like a band of countries like
California. Was the country better though?
When isn't that better
for the people is better.
So then that would mean you
know at the same rate, you know,
it's better to have a country like the
United States than to be well so said the
Republicans with states,
you can go to any state with countries,
you can go to any country. You can't get
an in Japan. I mean Japan. I mean, yeah,
you can't get in there
10 Syrians I think or something.
What'd you say?
The Japanese took like 10 Syrians
are trying to get him to Canada.
I was gonna say kids
these days, they have a,
they have very liberal immigration.
Kevin is obese.
The living cause these celebrities,
like I'm so sick of Dominican, his ways.
I'm headed to Canada. If you have a
Dui and I'll let you win. It's true.
It's apiece. Got To pay. That's crazy.
Boys. Let's wrap this bitch that's
wrap this up. It's uh, three 20.
We watched a couple of fights. I feel like
I'm in New York next Friday. Saturday.
You're doing standup comedy
in New York City, correct?
Are you doing Gotham comedy club? Yes. I
love that spot. You such a great place.
And then k.com yes.
And then a shoot my one hour showtime
special January 19th, January 19th,
San Diego, the fucker comedy
Chicago. December 15th,
Adzenys me and Sam triplink
and then a website. Uh,
just saying he's in Chicago.
He doesn't have like a tin foil out
comedy.com or something like that, man.
Not Be at the Irvine Improv for new years.
Beautiful.
Or ones that fucking new spot suite. I
heard it's really slow. You went to it?
Yeah. Yeah, I've done it. Yeah. I love
it. It's a newer than the last one. Well,
how new is it? Did it move a gun?
No, Bray is all, it is all new.
I'm talking to everybody. It's been
great. So awesome. Yeah. Done. Yeah.
Kevin shot a special debt. That's right,
bitch. I was there. Yeah. Okay. Fuck.
I was here before you even did
comedy son. Oh Shit. Oh Shit.
Until I was in the bathroom. You had done
comedy. Yeah, that's right. That's right.
Did you were in the crowd? Not In the
back. You were in the crowd at one show,
I think, weren't you sure? Oh
yeah. I was in the back then.
Went to the craft because I
opened up for crazy. Alright,
bye everybody. We love you guys
and girls and everybody else.
You guys want to go see
Tito chuck the de facto?
No.
Is it going to be on.